Too Fun and we're live.
Mr.
West.
Mr Mr Brogan,
have pleasure to have you here in
person.
Doing it on skype was fun and it was
nice.
And you are to this day,
the only podcast I've ever done on
skype.
Really?
Yup.
Yeah.
But I just had to talk to you.
There's like if you couldn't get down
here,
there's gotta be a way.
So it was nice to be able to do it that
way,
but much nicer to see here in person.
And let's better to be here in person
and actually what responsible if it
would be being here in person is that I
wouldn't actually come all this huge
distance even to be on your show unless
you paid me lots of money.
Of course we did not prepare to do but,
but because I have this conference
coming up at the end of the week called
Seapak,
which I'm surprised you didn't know that
conference on precession and ancient
knowledge,
uh,
which is the end of this week for those
living in southern California.
Might want to,
uh,
take,
I'll take a look at the word sell it.
Tell everybody where,
where's that and what is it about?
It's Rancho Mirage,
which is a great name and means there is
no ranch but um,
Ron Tomo hires,
which is somewhere near palm springs and
it is about exactly what it says
conference on precession and ancient
knowledge and did it questions to begin
with the whole.
Um,
so I say the whole,
the whole scenario,
the standards scenario of that,
what causes procession,
which is supposedly a kind of a wobble
of the earth caused by,
nobody knows exactly what and the
counter theory is that it isn't that
it's that there is a dwarf star of some
sort orbiting the sun,
upsetting the balance of the celestial
mechanical balance of it.
And that makes a difference.
You say,
well what's the difference one way or
another?
There's procession.
It doesn't make a difference actually in
the big picture because it means that
our solar system basically conforms with
all of the other solar systems,
which mostly are dual in nature.
A serious,
for example,
as the Dwarf Star that circled around
it,
series b,
that's responsible for all sorts of
measurable phenomena.
So it starts off from there,
but then the ancient knowledge comes in
because precession and this is a big
mystery.
Precession seems to be a factor of
virtually every ancient society be it
sophisticated.
I'll let China and India,
South America,
Mesoamerica or so called primitive a
word I hate to use.
It simply means an intellectual lies or
not expressed in coherent western
philosophy for whatever that's worth.
The the um,
but er procession is,
is a known fact,
um,
discovered actually long time ago you'd
think by now it would be common
knowledge and everybody would teach it
in school,
which is a sort of a joke.
I'm interesting to people don't teach
it.
Right.
It is a very bizarre
thing that it's,
it's so prominent in ancient cultures,
in ancient society that they literally
map this out,
this 26,000
year cycle.
It's wobble of the earth
and that we rarely talk about it ever.
No,
because it upsets the notion that
there's a knowledge of this going back
to ancient times presupposes that
there's a very advanced observational
astronomy dating at a time when
supposedly people were still living in
trees.
So this is actually a big deal.
Hence the conference on precession and
the ancient knowledge comes into it
because understanding that there is a
highly sophisticated scientific
understanding that goes back not just to
ancient Egypt itself but far thousands
and thousand millennia beyond upsets
what is effectively the reigning
religion of today except that doesn't
call itself a religion.
It calls itself science which is based
supposedly on reason.
It's dot.
None of those things are true.
It's not based on science and science is
not based upon reason.
Maybe we'll get it,
well some sciences,
but archeology in particular is very
rigid and its ideas and a lot of it is
based on the professors that have
written books and that teach these ideas
and they don't want to let them go.
And when noon knowledge is discovered
that challenges those ideas,
they fight it rigorously even if it's
knowledge like the stuff that you
exposed with doctor Ron Shock,
Robert Schoch rather,
which was the water erosion on the
Sphinx,
which we were talking about before the
podcast is,
which is one of the best pieces of
evidence because the last time there was
rainfall heavy rainfall in the Nile
Valley was,
what was it,
9,000
vcs that what it was.
They debate it,
but it's anyway,
it's way before the beginning of
dynastic Egypt.
And then it's a question of how,
how have,
how old are when those rains fell
because it's big bit of that of thing
here that I'm now at liberty to um,
to relate publicly.
Originally,
I wasn't when I first got chocolate,
where do Egypt,
which is another two hour podcast in
itself.
The history of getting shock interested
in this stuff.
And when he finally agreed very
hesitantly and very skeptically to come
along because he had to see the evidence
for my s for himself and I scraped
together a bit of money to bring them
over and we got into the swings and
closure.
I don't think it was luke got in
legally.
I think we bribed our way and very early
in the morning,
well and Egypt,
everything is possible and bribed our
way in.
And he walked into the swinks and
closure.
Actually when we get that up on the
screen,
you'll see the,
the,
the level of the water,
the extent of the weathering of the
water,
weathering and chalk looked at it and
everybody else walks into the sinks and
closure and has this actually this shock
of recognition of the presence of this
fabulous work of,
of sacred art,
sculpture in fact of sacred sculpture
and chocolate with chocolate is a,
as a,
uh,
no,
that's not,
it was to go way back to Tammy,
right to the beginning,
first slides and shock.
Everybody else sees the spanx as a work
of art.
Shock sees the rocks and he's a
geologist and he back like this and he
said,
Oh wow,
these rocks look like they're hundreds
of thousands of years old.
And he said,
don't quote me on that because that's of
course absolute heresy that the most
spectacular sculpture on earth should
be.
I mean,
tens of thousands of years actually,
even th th th the 4,500
years that are,
that it's associated with do not conform
with anybody's idea of how civilization
developed.
This goes back to your,
of why the,
the academic,
I call it the academic establishment is
so is so passionately,
um,
defends the old paradigm the way that it
does because of the reigning paradigm,
the trainings religion today,
which is not acknowledged,
that has religion,
is that this is,
this is the Church of progress and its
credo just like the virgin birth is the
Credo of,
of early Christianity or a present day
Christianity.
Not that they know what they're talking
about.
Um,
the,
the Credo of the Church of progress is
a,
we are the most sophisticated human
beings that have ever lived on the face
of the planet with our hydrogen bombs
and our nerve gas in our stripe
toothpaste and our Disneyland's were the
best that ever was.
And secondly,
that progress as it's called,
goes in a straight line from primitive
caveman up to ourselves.
And when it becomes self evident that in
very,
very ancient times they had knowledge of
precession,
which is an incredible thing to it.
It's almost unimaginable that it happens
through careful observation because the
sun,
I don't know if all of the audience will
know what what this is.
So maybe it's worth talking about the
sun.
If you look at the spring equinox now,
it's in the last,
the sun is rising against the last,
um,
the last bits of,
of,
um,
of Pisces.
It may even be in the earliest stages of
Aquarius and the gradually the Sun
precesses that's to say it goes
backwards around the Zodiac in a cycle
that takes 25,000
canonically 25,000,
920 years to make a complete circle.
What this means is that it actually
takes 72 years precisely for the sun to
precess one degree.
So this is nothing who's going to be
sitting there for 72 years watching the
track of the sun in a,
in a,
in a cycle that takes 26,000
years to go around and observe that
there's a discrepancy and then pass that
information down.
And then why should they care somehow or
another deeply connected with the
civilization of that time and with our
civilization.
When you look at the numbers involved,
this is another hours of conversation
accurately.
The 72 in the 73 are significant numbers
in practically all of the developed
numerologically based society.
So in Egypt set,
who's the bad guy?
Derivative?
Probably Satan is derived from set.
He's the bad guy,
but he's also a great God.
That is to say the gods are not gods in
any superstitious fashion.
They represented the embodiments of
cosmic principles,
so excuse me,
set is he who fixes spirit and matter
and the whole basis of an esoteric of
any esoteric doctrine including most of
the religions that are around even today
and they're deprived forms.
The objective of any esoteric discipline
is to free ourselves individually and
collectively for imprisonment and
matter.
This is the question.
We're in mortality and so in some sense
or another that processional cycle is
very important than the numbers are
important in the myth,
which again,
we don't have time for,
but Ozar,
iris is the good king.
Actually.
This is all very carefully,
uh,
expounded very brilliantly.
In fact,
in the hamlet myth,
it's become Shakespeare's hamlet and
then in the lion king and Disney's lion
king and the movies especially,
which is really pretty brilliant anyway,
set as the good king who is beloved by
his people and set his,
his wicked brother is evil brother who
was determined to unseat him than steal
his sister wife Isis while he's at it.
Anyway,
sets,
sets a trap for Ozar Harris and it's,
it's set and it's 72 followers.
So 72 is this number associated with the
time and the 72 to 73 is a very
significant ratio actually,
which pervades the philosophies of,
as I said,
of all of the esoteric civilizations.
So all of this stuff,
instead of all of this,
instead of being the kind of ask a quack
academic,
the same guy you were talking about
earlier,
it still thinks the six is weathered by
sand.
Ask One of those,
what ancient myth is about and they say,
oh,
well it's just a fabrication written by
primitive people who are trying to
explain the mysteries of the universe.
It's the other way around.
The perimeter of people are the ones
with the phds.
And back then they not only did they
understand these scientific,
these astronomical,
these astronomical facts,
but they orchestrated their whole
civilization around those facts.
And the more,
the deeper you get into this,
the more miraculous,
um,
the,
the extent of ancient knowledge becomes
what is the mainstream explanation when
they,
when they talk about the prevalence of
the number 72 and their understanding of
the procession of the equinoxes,
do they address it at all?
Like how do they,
how do they sort of explain how they
knew about this 26,000
year cycle?
I was at a very quick answer to that
actually.
For a change.
No,
they just explained it's just ignore.
He's,
it's sorta like the Parthenon,
the Acropolis,
you know,
which one is the Acropolis is the
building and the Parthenon is a
structure,
right?
Is that what it is?
No breeze.
Both their temples about the buildings,
but what does the,
uh,
what's the,
the,
the base,
the base is the one that they don't
explain,
right?
They just go,
well,
we don't really,
exactly.
That's the gigantic,
enormous base,
the huge stones that the Acropolis is
built on.
Right.
Because don't goes up.
Acropolis is the one on top.
Right.
Okay.
See the Parthenon is what they're built
on this,
the base structure where whatever it is,
the,
the bottom area.
I don't know,
actually,
I've never really looked that deeply
into it.
Other than that,
there's a friend of mine who's worked
with the proportions and the
sophisticated proportions of the
Parthenon,
and it shows actually that it's as,
as my noodly orchestrated as anything in
Egypt,
even though it's much better than Egypt,
but much later than Egypt.
But no one knows who built it and no one
knows why they built it.
It's one of those weird ones where it's
not really described and the tax and the
Acropolis is built upon it.
Um,
he said,
some explained to me by,
by Greek historians,
by people understand Greek history.
They just really don't understand where
it came from.
Well,
I believe that's true,
except that I think it's pretty certain
that it's not,
it's not of Egyptian age,
although if you're talking about
gigantic paving stones at the bottom of
it is that,
I don't know.
But whenever you see those gigantic
stones,
that's a pretty good indication of an
earlier period of construction.
As at Baalbek,
they have these monolithic 1200 ton
blocks that they think the Romans put
in.
And that's in Lebanon,
right?
That's Lebanon.
Yeah.
So there's a ton of this,
of this kind of indirect evidence.
And when you put it all together,
you get,
there's enough of a picture there so
that it overthrows the basis.
I said,
what's important about it is up one
sentence.
Who Cares?
In another sense,
it overthrows the suppose scientific
basis of the Church of progress that
we're the most sophisticated people that
have aware and we can do whatever we
pleased with this once glorious planet
of ours without worrying about it
because we're the best in everyone.
Before us was primitive.
Well,
there's a lot of new evidence now since
you started your work.
Um,
particularly all that nuclear glass that
they're finding that corresponds with
meteor impacts throughout Europe and
Asia and that that's somewhere around
the end of the ice age really in the
same sort of a time period when they do
core samples and they find this nuclear
glass,
it's all at around 10,000
plus years ago.
Um,
that kind of stuff really starts to
indicate that we're looking at possibly
an event that might've shaped human
history or a reset of a large percentage
of,
of the people on this planet where
civilization in many areas was all but
wiped out.
And then they had to rebuild again.
Yeah.
This is,
I mean,
actually this is coming to the fore now.
There's a lot of evidence for these.
I think that's the tektites their code,
um,
shock thinks that they are the result of
a gigantic cme,
coronal mass ejection,
giant solar flares,
and does a lot of evidence with this.
Actually,
we know if we get into talking about it
here,
I will at sea pack for short of shock
will be its effect anyway.
The,
that it's,
but it's,
it's unlikely that it's actually a
nuclear blast because it would be
inconceivable,
well,
at least by our standards,
a manmade nuclear blast.
Although when you go into the Hindu
texts,
and I think it's the upanishads where
they describe what sounds like,
I mean it's described as a battle of the
gods,
but for all the world it does sound
like,
like a nuclear conflagration,
a bit of a human made nuclear
conflagration.
I'm not,
I don't think anybody knows enough to
say what it is other than that,
that story is in there.
In fact,
one of the,
I'm a,
because I'm a writer by trade,
I'm very interested in the way that that
language is used.
And so myth is one of the,
one of the principle of misleading words
that,
um,
if you look in the dictionary,
the first stick,
the first meaning that it gives for myth
is a lie.
You were talking about the myth because
mythbusters goes to them.
That myth is ally,
but the ancients didn't see myth is a
lie.
What myth actually is when you get into
it fairly deeply is it is the,
it is the interplay of cosmic principles
described as drama rather than in
mathematics.
So once you get a good look at this is
extraordinary but opaque book called
hamlet's mill by George Joe Desante,
Yana and heritage on deck and two tour
historians of science at Mit,
which is about as respectable as
credentials can be.
So as soon as,
as soon as myth is understood as having
both a rigorous scientific as well as,
as well as philosophical and spiritual
base,
the whole,
the whole understanding of myth turns
around.
And you'll see,
for example,
in hamlet and Shakespeare's hamlet,
which is based upon the Danish,
it was based upon a Danish folk tale,
um,
which then becomes quite brilliantly
actually the lion king.
Uh,
in the Disney film.
You see how the myth,
I mean,
in other words,
you can decode the ohs,
Iris Isis,
Horace Smith as,
as pure as pure science,
and it might call us a spiritual or
sacred science.
And at the same time that the ripping
good story when you,
when you put it that way,
a story because then everybody can
understand it even if they don't
understand it,
even if they can't articulate what
they've understood,
the power of the story soaks through.
So myth is actually the more you know
about it,
my case is not that much,
but at least it's better than nothing.
Um,
the more you know about it,
the more amazing mythology becomes that
they should have been able to put
together these complex,
high hierarchical,
esoteric concepts in a way that
resonates as a story otherwise,
in so far as,
I mean,
our own cosmology is next to impossible
to understand unless you are a
cosmologist and schooled in the abstract
mathematics that make the thing work.
I mean,
I can't,
I mean the mathematics is absolutely
beyond me,
but some of my astrophysicist trends can
explain it to me in such a way that I
understand,
but it still doesn't have any emotional
impact.
So essentially what you're saying is
that they didn't have the sort of
scientific discipline that we have
today.
They didn't understand a lot of the
things that we know today as far as a,
the way,
um,
academics or scientists relay
information about space or about
cosmology.
So what they did is they combined
theater and story with the actual facts
that they knew.
So that was the way they would relay
this stuff.
And that's the way that stuff would be
passed on that information to be passed
on through these stories.
But in those stories was an actual
history of the world itself as far as
they knew.
Right
through,
through that and through symbolism.
And this is,
this is an infinitely superior way of
communicating knowledge because you
don't have to be an expert.
You'll,
it soaks into your bones in such a way
that it,
okay,
it direct personally and collectively
people's behaviors.
And it's my firm conviction that this is
why Egypt lasted as a coherent
civilization,
even in its dynastic form,
but 3,500
years
and our lunatic societies coming apart
at the seams in front of our eyes at 300
years.
I wanted to talk to you about the,
the written history of Egypt and the
hieroglyphic history of the pharaohs
because,
uh,
I remember,
I think it was from magical Egypt one
when you were talking about the
historical record,
like what they have written down in the
hieroglyphs about the pharaohs,
that it goes back far beyond what we
think of as the birth of Egypt.
You know,
with the,
the,
the construction,
the great pyramid.
I believe they put it modern academics
put it at 2,500
BC,
correct?
Yes.
And they,
you believe that it's possible that
Egypt existed as far back as,
I think you said 34,000
years.
Well,
that's,
that's their own,
that's the Egyptians account,
not mine,
right.
Course.
As expressed as expressed in a couple
of,
in a couple of an in a stone tablet
called the Palermo stone because it's
now in Palermo,
Italy.
Um,
and in a very fragmentary papyruses
called the Turin papyrus,
which is now in Turin.
And both of these documents.
One is a stone stele and the other is a
hippopotamus tell or recount.
Um,
long periods when Egypt was ruled first
by the net chodo which means the gods
themselves,
which I take to mean fully,
fully realized divine human beings.
In other words,
human beings that have attained,
that have passed the,
the test of the quest of it.
Four in mortality who are in effect,
they've outsmarted death or they've out
developed debt.
You why do you believe this?
Um,
because their work speak for themselves
as it were.
Um,
and the,
the,
the level of the,
now we talked going back even to an even
to um,
to dynastic Egypt because the temples
themselves and the level of art
involved,
particularly in the sculpture is such
that standard.
I say stay genius is rare enough,
but standard human genius doesn't seem
to apply to these incredible
constructions.
And the core academics simply dismiss it
out of hand is really very talented.
Um,
exponent of a barbaric and um,
and primitive understanding of the
cosmos.
I leading my trips there,
which I do as you know,
a few times a year.
The next one coming up.
By the way,
anybody listening in,
how could people go in on one of those
trips with you?
Oh,
it's very easy.
You pay.
Okay.
Where do they,
where do they find you though?
On my website.
Um,
John Anthony.
west.com.
Yeah.
On the website or,
or my,
my email.
J A w spanx at AOL dot.
Oh,
you messed up.
You give your email.
That's a disaster.
Is it?
My people.
Horrible people are going to send you
naked pictures for sure.
Oh,
not of themselves.
I am I familiar with the term Dick pic
cause it's,
yeah,
there you go.
Um,
so your,
your thoughts are that these people that
live 34,000
years ago were incredibly advanced,
much further advanced than we are today,
which doesn't take much.
But when you understand what's involved,
but yeah,
I know what you're saying,
but I mean we're,
we're pretty damn advanced compared to
the people a few hundred years ago or in
certain ways we are abreast.
We still can't,
we couldn't,
we couldn't and wouldn't build the
cathedral of shots.
Yeah.
Nobody,
there's nobody alive.
To the best of my knowledge,
who could produce a building that is
based upon sacred principles that even
comes close to sacred geometry and set
grieve.
Even that,
I mean a few people really know quite a
bit about this,
but they couldn't design Jada and that's
well that's 12th century.
What was it about Egypt and that time in
particular that in your opinion,
I mean obviously there's a lot of
speculation going on here because
there's so little evidence from 34,000
years ago,
but what is it about that area that you
think develop people at such an
incredibly high level?
Cause unless there's more evidence to be
found there,
it doesn't seem to be any parallels
anywhere else in the world.
Like that one spot.
And actually there's,
there's a fairly,
there's a fairly simple explanation for
that,
for a change it,
most of this stuff is so complicated,
but just to go back a bit to the,
the rule by the net shit who,
the gods themselves and the names of
those real is a given and the length of
time that they reigned.
And then there's another group of
[inaudible] the lines,
the line of time is incredible.
Right?
Well this is where we're getting the
34,000,
36,000
BC from.
Yeah,
because you add the,
the time's up.
The Turin for pirates has a similar
thing of the net that reign rule of the
net shadow and the rule by the,
it's called the [inaudible],
the followers of the,
the followers of the companions of
horace.
And again,
the names are given and the regularly
as,
and when you add those all up together,
you get around 34 36,000
BC,
four does this some,
I'm sorry to interrupt you,
but Warren,
some of the pharaohs,
didn't they live hundreds of years.
There's no evidence for that.
But wasn't it written that they did?
I'm not sure.
I'm not sure what those dates are
actually.
I've not actually deeply researched
them.
I get those figures from [inaudible],
the UBX,
the great genius with the
unpronounceable name who put together
the whole interpretation of symbolist
Egypt from which my work is derived.
I mean,
I regard myself as Schweller's Boswell,
um,
making his basically impenetrable work
of accessible,
accessible to dummies like me.
No smart guys,
smart guys like you and not dumb.
He's like politicians and quack
academics.
No,
but when you're talking about 34,000
years,
I mean the average person today lives to
be about 80 years.
You're talking about an incredible
number of pharaoh's then.
Yeah,
you are.
And so all that is depicted apparently,
apparently the names,
the names are given that I get that from
Schwaller from the one from the one long
chapter he wrote called the,
the,
the chronology choreography.
He calls it [inaudible] not the word for
it,
but the chronology of Egypt where he's
looking to back up to 200 from a
scholarly point of view,
for the mode of the scholarly argument
that the Egyptians knew what they were
talking about when they were assigning
these long reins.
That these are not fictitious.
Um,
this is not made up history that in
order to you fool the people who
couldn't read the hieroglyphs anyway,
only describes,
could read the hieroglyphs.
So the trawler wrote this very long and
thoughtful and scholarly,
um,
lecture,
I,
sorry,
not lecture,
but that chapter.
And then at the very end of it,
this throwaway line and does of course
the Great Sphinx of Giza has been
weathered,
chose unmistakable signs of aquatic
erosion.
And that was my little epiphany because
I picked up on that and said,
wow,
the rest of this isn't science,
but that's geology.
And if the geologists can be,
you know,
can will agree that this is,
this cannot have taken place since 2,500
years,
2,500
bc when the synxis supposedly built this
will upset the whole paradigm.
All of civilization will have to be,
our view of civilization will have to be
rethought.
And that's began.
There's a long,
long now,
four decade long quest to find somebody
to back it up.
And we're now,
my sense of it is closing in on beating
down the opposition.
And this'll be another thing I took.
In fact,
I'll probably be talking about at
Seapak,
but probably have with how so I said a
little bit more politely than I feel it
necessary to talk about here.
I'm here with you and that is riffing on
a line that probably everybody who tunes
into this is pro is familiar with
victor,
who goes to the French poet,
novelist,
a dramatist of the 19th century France.
Actually Frances,
most most popular poet of the,
of the 19th century was v Victor Hugo,
and it was Victor Hugo who wrote the
famous line.
There's one thing stronger than all the
armies in the world and that is an idea
whose time has come.
You know that line,
right?
Everybody knows that line.
But what victor who go didn't think of,
or if he did,
he didn't express it was that the
strongest thing in the world is an idea
whose time has not yet gone.
And since it is,
it is a matter of record that all of the
armies in the world be they military,
economic,
financial,
cultural,
agricultural,
even wherever there's a paradigm,
there's an army devoted to protecting
that paradigm.
And this is where we stand now,
that,
that the idea whose time has come only
comes when the second strongest,
the armies of the second strongest thing
in the world are beaten down and beaten
into the ground and somebody breaches
the Portcullis to the ivory tower where
all of these guys live.
And this is a particular interest to me
because I am a scholar by default,
but a satirist by nature.
And really my whole,
my whole adult life has been devoted to
proving a vision that I had at the age
of 13 or so.
But I was born into a lunatic asylum.
And at the age of about 19,
it was a very uncomfortable place to
live where everybody's called the
progress.
And I thought it was crazy.
And at that age,
about 19 or so,
I knew what I wanted to do,
which was to be the little boy who said
the emperor has no clothes and to prove
to everybody's satisfaction that indeed
the emperor has no clothes and it's a
lunatic asylum.
The end result took me a few couple of
decades to realize that it was that,
um,
in,
in real life what happens is that no,
the people all older,
they will look,
the emperor has no clothes and everybody
lives happily ever after.
What happens is that the disgraced
amparo gets up and goes back to his,
goes back to his palace and regroups the
empire.
And at the end they,
all of the,
all of the forces of empire conspire to
prove to everyone that the emperor's
clothes are real.
But it's the child who's imaginary.
Talking about this before the podcast,
and this is a really fascinating aspect
of this discussion,
was yours,
when I first became aware of your work,
was that Charlton Heston narrated
documentary about the aging of the
Sphinx,
the mystery of the Sphinx,
which I believe is on NBC.
Uh,
what,
what I thought was shocking was when Dr
Shock was speaking to that Egypt
tologist who was saying what evidence is
there of a culture that existed 7,000
years before ancient Egypt?
What?
There's no evidence.
He's like theories.
No.
And he was laughing and the way he was
doing it was so much ego involved and
what he was saying,
I was like,
wow,
this is not how I would picture an
Egypt.
Tologist laughing.
Well that got me curious.
I started getting into it.
Why would anybody think like that?
And then I realized,
oh,
these guys write books and they teach
lectures and they teach classes based on
this that they're,
they're teaching and now this
information has been shown to be not
true anymore.
When doctor shock was showing this water
erosion,
he was saying that this was all before
the discovery of gold Beckley tappy and
once they discovered go Beckley Tapi,
now they know that there was a
sophisticated structure capable of
massive stones circles.
That was 12,000
years ago at least when it was
intentionally buried.
So it could have easily been several
thousand years old then we don't know.
But we know at least 12,000
years ago someone was capable of
incredible design and incredible stone
structures with three dimensional
animals carved into the stone
structures,
which is very sophisticated now.
Has that guy been talked to since then?
And has he amended his position on it?
As far as I know he hasn't and I know
laner reasonably well.
We're civil to each other and it won't
be long.
I mean he's the,
he's,
he's one of the generals of the,
uh,
in the,
in,
in the army of the idea whose time has
not yet gone.
And his,
his time is coming up pretty good.
Does he dress,
go back,
Lee tappy now me cause his whole,
his whole position was there was no
civilization.
What evidence is there?
Well now that you have this evidence,
what does he say?
I haven't actually spoken to him and I
don't know if anyone has,
I see him in Egypt every once in a
while.
I don't know if anyone has.
And I said I ran into him fairly
recently.
He just said hello.
And I don't think I'd really,
I'd necessarily want to bring it up with
them.
Um,
off the record.
I'd rather have him that the camera's on
us and just see what happens.
But otherwise,
otherwise,
otherwise he's a dead duck.
But it's just so he,
he seems to be just clinging to this
idea because he can,
like in mainstream academia hasn't
accepted this predating of the Sphinx
or,
or also the,
the difference in the structures,
like the difference in the construction
methods that were used.
One of the more fascinating things that
you sort of highlighted in your ancient
Egypt,
a series magical Egypt,
which is fantastic and I highly
recommend it to anybody who is even
remotely curious to this.
You will be sucked in in an incredible
way.
It got to the point where my wife was
walking by the TV,
she's like,
Jesus Christ,
you're watching Egypt again.
And I'm like,
it's,
it's like six disks that goes on
forever.
Eight.
Um,
so the different,
there's a clear distinction between the
older methods of construction and the
newer methods.
They use different methods and it's
really obvious to someone like me who's
not even a,
I don't know anything about it,
but you could see the difference and
also that these older structures were
below the newer structures.
Like you had a dig down to get them.
That's right.
Yeah.
It's like the fact that they don't
address that.
The fact that this isn't,
that's like they want to lump this all
into the same people,
kind of crazy.
It is and but as long as they can get
away with it,
they will continue to get away with it.
As I said,
the second,
the second strongest thing in the world
is the idea whose time has not yet gone
and anybody who doesn't,
let's say among myself,
between myself and my colleagues are all
in this,
let's say the,
the,
the question to prove,
to demonstrate that the advanced
civilization existed in the very distant
past,
which is in my case other cases,
not necessarily,
but in mine it's because that opens the
door in and of itself,
doesn't the pro,
it doesn't affect the price of eggs,
but on a much more profound
philosophical level.
Once it's understood that that
understanding that civilization goes,
went back way much,
much further leads to the understanding
and the acceptance that our role,
our destiny as human beings is to
achieve in mortality.
This is as simple as all as that.
Otherwise it's just a head trip.
In other words,
if it's not understood that we have a
role to play in this grand cosmic state
scheme,
there's no civilization.
What do you mean by that?
Our,
our,
our goal is to achieve in mortality.
Do you mean as individuals or do you
mean like and what's in what way?
That we,
we arrive at a level of consciousness
that is not subject to the death of the
physical body,
so all of religion is based upon that.
All of the,
the stories of the saints and the Rachis
and the masters and so on is based upon
all of it is based upon their
experiences that have led them to this
understanding.
If it's just a head trip,
it's no good.
It has to be part of your very being.
The purpose of sacred art is to end of
sacred music when it works is to
communicate even if only momentarily and
fragmentary.
Really this understanding that there's
something else.
And speaking from my own personal
experiences,
I've never gone through a full blown
mystical experience,
but I've had lots of these moments,
particularly in Egypt and the long study
and these moments in Egypt where there's
this sudden realization that the world
as it as it has,
it manifests to our,
our,
our faculties are normal faculties is
not the only world there is this
something else beyond that,
which was understood a lot better in
those days than now.
And actually when we end up,
I forgot to mention this,
but I don't know if you know this.
I've been spent the last couple of years
sort of sidetracked from my regular work
working on a book written by a friend of
mine.
Good.
Um,
who was not a writer.
So I helped him with the editing and
contributed to it.
And this is maybe the definitive book on
envy and the ease.
You know what those are,
right near death experience,
death experiences.
He was a Christian pastor,
a rare guy who actually lived what he
preached named David Solomon,
and he had collected all of this
material,
huge amount of material that he was
trying to systematize because this is
now,
it's certainly not a common experience,
but there are 5,000
verifiable accounts of people who have
been clinically dead and who have been
revived usually but through modern
methods because now one of the reasons
why it's now so common and before it was
reserved for the saints,
the Great Saints and the mystics that
modern medicine has,
has,
has improved to such an extent that if
you get to these people quickly enough,
any number of people who are clinically
dead for x number of minutes,
you know,
not two days minutes,
sometimes more extended period than that
come back with these tales of this
realm.
Beyond that of the senses,
a realm of higher consciousness.
Basically what it is,
what they've experienced is his grace.
In Christian terms,
it's grace,
it's a,
it's a moment.
Then they come back transformed and they
come back convinced that everything that
they were doing before is either
nonsense or unimportant.
Then they often come back with a mission
even though they don't have the
schooling,
let's say.
They don't understand philosophically or
spiritually what they've experienced.
They know what they've experienced and
they laugh at the debunkers who are
saying it's all brown hallucination of
the brain dying brain.
This is all garbage.
What they've experienced,
they've experienced,
and David put these together in a
systematic fashion and then as he was
just a Diclectin,
all this material,
and I was telling him this is that he's
a good friend.
He financed our trip to go the tap pay
five,
six years ago and he started losing his
balance and he was a touchy guy who
knows a lot about balance.
Also a bonsai master and the Christian
Pastor,
unusual guy,
and he started losing his balance and it
wasn't going away and the doctors
finally figured out what he had,
what it was wrong with them and he had a
Glioma,
Glioblastoma,
something.
I forget purpose.
It's something.
Do you know what a Glioma is?
Because it's a form of brain cancer that
is 100% fatal.
It's the only thing you have is that you
can't determine the timeline.
And they gave him something like 10
months to 12 months to live.
They actually lived three years.
And at that point he had all of this
material.
And I told him when he was telling me
that,
I said,
hey dude,
I should write a book.
This is really good stuff.
The way you're doing it is not like
anybody else has ever done.
And he said,
no,
I'm not a writer.
I'm just doing this.
And then when he found out the
diagnosis,
then he had a mission,
which was to get the book out,
but
he wasn't a writer.
So he drafted me into,
they'll put the words in ride harder and
he lasted just long enough to get the
book finished and get it published.
And it's,
it's,
it's really,
if this went viral,
it could make a difference.
It's called,
he was very good at titled David.
um,
it's called the dead saints chronicles
subtitle,
a,
um,
a zen journey through the Christian
afterlife.
And it really,
it really is an absolutely extraordinary
book and it becomes quite clear when you
go through this that what people have
experienced is a state of grace that's
not all the same.
I mean some people it's more profound
and some people less so,
but all of these people are unprepared
for what they've experienced and all of
them come back transformed.
And of course the cracker dynamics.
This is one of the ways they protect
themselves.
Peer Review was one way and the other is
their insistence.
Who the hell made?
We gave them the right to make the rules
from science that applied to science
with the scientist that that makes,
gives them the right,
the big the rules,
know the rules of the rules and one of
their insists,
one of the chief element,
one of the chief ways in which they
protect themselves is to insist that
anecdotal evidence,
personal experience doesn't count.
I don't know about you,
but I wouldn't buy a cookbook by someone
who's never fried an egg.
So these are guys who've never fried a
spiritual egg and these 5,000
accounts or people who've actually been
there to this superior realm and come
back to talk about it.
No.
You say you haven't had a mystical
experience.
You mean a psychedelic experience?
Know that I've had yet.
You've had psychedelic trance,
which kind of psychedelic experiences
behind Oh,
blood done Iowasca and I've done 10.
I've done,
you know,
you name it.
Right.
So then,
so you've done dmt.
Yes,
I've done and I've done a,
not Mescalin,
but um,
the other one out acid.
Okay.
All of those.
No,
no.
The experience has come actually for me,
as I said,
they're not a major,
it's not the state of grace that these
people,
you didn't experience a state of grace
when you did DMT.
Not Quite,
no,
not,
not compared to what the,
the,
uh,
the MDS.
The ask how many times you've done it?
One.
One time.
Okay.
Did you do a lot of it?
I don't know.
He gotta do a lot of it.
Yeah.
I made you just dissolve.
Did you go to this crazy geometric,
infinite universe where you're coming?
I didn't,
he didn't get in there then.
I didn't get,
I didn't need how long you in town for?
Pardon?
How long you in town for?
Till tomorrow we're going to have to
make something happen.
You got up,
you got to go deeper.
That experience that people are having
and near death experience is mirrored by
the same extent.
You,
I'm sure you're aware of Doctor Rick
strassman.
Oh yeah,
sure,
sure.
Um,
he,
I believe actually we met them when
chance was doing the brilliant guy.
It's so important because what has
created
by his book,
Dmt,
the spirit molecule,
they did these clinical tests giving
people dmt in a clinical setting and a
at the University of New Mexico.
And what they found was these people
achieve this incredible state of
understanding,
um,
a more relaxed,
a vision of the future.
They're more confident,
like the,
the idea,
I mean this is also mirrored by some of
the John Hopkins tested they've done
with people with silicide been where
people have,
uh,
you know,
they have just a much better outlook
about the future.
They don't think that this is it and
that whatever happens to them when
they're having these trips.
And the way strassman did it as much
more intense and most people do it
because they did intravenous doses,
which lasts longer.
A typical dmt trip last only about 15
minutes,
unless you just jump right back in,
which is what I usually do.
But he,
um,
he gave these people to intravenous
doses,
which to take them just very deep for
more than a half an hour.
And they all have very similar stories
and similar stores to people that have
had near death experiences.
I've had friends that have had near
death experiences and when they talk
about it,
it's very similar to the way I've talked
to other people that have had dmt trips,
where they are in the presence of this
divine greatness.
There's something.
So,
but that is also a chemical that's
produced by the brain.
Now this is where,
uh,
neuroscientists step in and say,
well,
your experiences is experiencing is some
sort of a hallucination and a,
they might be right,
but it also might be some sort of a
chemical gateway that your brain
produces when we really don't know.
And that might be the way the soul,
quote unquote air quotes,
whatever.
But for lack of a better word,
transitions to this next stage of life.
Now when the anecdotal evidence that
you're talking about is measuring up,
what's interesting about it is similar
accounts over and over and over and over
again.
The people that can remember things,
they remember this incredibly divine
experience.
But you know,
the question becomes is that experience,
and this is something that I've been
bouncing,
bouncing around in my head a lot lately,
is that experience a hallucination or
has that experience and actual real
experience in a divine presence?
And does it matter?
Because is it the same thing no matter
what?
If you just think you're experiencing
God and divine greatness because you're
creating it in your mind versus actually
experiencing God and divine greatness.
Isn't the experience the exact same
thing and is is our mine locked into the
idea of a physical thing like this
laptop?
I can pick it up,
I can drop it.
I know it has weight,
I can touch it.
I can measure the width.
We can't do that with psychedelic
experiences.
We can't do that with transcendent
We can't do that with mystical
experiences.
You can't measure them.
You can't put them in a bag and take it
home with you,
but it might be the same thing.
It's entirely possible that this is what
a many,
many ancient cultures experienced as
well.
They found these of psychedelics very
odd for early on and this is also
something that you documented your work
and they date documented it very clearly
in a lot of the d Egyptian work.
They had deep understanding and
knowledge.
Exactly.
Joe,
this is one of the important things
about the drugs,
the drugs and the NDE experiences.
In my view,
the ND experiences,
marcel,
because there's nothing in the way.
There's nothing obstructing it.
The dead.
Right.
And this is where they go with the
drugs.
You're,
you don't,
you,
you know,
you're you,
um,
in these experiences and the problem,
interesting.
There's problem I once it's not a
problem is the wrong word,
but,
um,
with the Nde experiences,
I mean,
absolutely joe six pack everybody,
ordinary people,
many of them,
some of them even atheists go through
this and come back,
literally transformed their whole lives,
have changed by with the drugs.
It really is for the most part,
it's a trip.
It doesn't have this,
let's say there's lasting
transformational value.
It doesn't,
some people it does sometimes.
Yes.
Well,
the John Hopkins study showed that a lot
of people,
like decades later,
I know a vaseline improved quality of
life,
different outlook on things.
And especially when you're dealing with
terminally ill patients.
Oh,
well.
And they've given it to terminally ill
patients,
significant lessening of anxiety and
fear of death.
Oh,
sure.
It would be.
But the hallucination,
this is another scam by the,
by the so called rationalists,
who in fact the not there.
This idea that it's a hallucination and
what's a hallucination and what's it's,
what's its evolutionary value?
Why should they be?
Where's the hallucination gene?
This is all bullshit actually.
And what it actually is,
is not based upon reason as they liked,
as they like to,
as they promote themselves,
what it is actually is the
rationalization of their own inner
emptiness.
They can't handle the fact that there
might be something else,
and in fact,
their whole intellectual lives are
consecrated to the,
to proving that life is indeed as
meaningless as their own.
But is that what it is?
Or is it,
they're just trying to look at some sort
of a,
give it a critical objective view and,
and go over all the possibilities.
We know that drugs do affect the mind in
very strange ways and we know some
people take drugs and it completely
distorts the reality.
Alcohol's a perfect example of that,
right?
Yeah.
It's a great drug for distorting
reality.
You can watch someone get drunk and have
a very bizarre version of the what of
what they're looking at.
Um,
there's many drugs that change the way
people look at things like physically
the way they see things.
They will hallucinate.
They,
they do.
So we know that drugs have an effect on
people.
I mean it seems rational though that a
scientist would look at those things and
try to find some sort of a scientific
explanation for the chemical process is
going on in the mind.
The way it's affecting the visual cortex
and the things that the person is quote
unquote hallucinating
underlying that contention,
which is not science in an of itself.
That is just a hypothesis.
That is speculation.
And I said,
what is based upon is protecting their
own vision of the world,
which is that the universe isn't,
is an accident and anything that is
mystical or sore,
so-called spiritual is hallucinatory.
And they have the answers.
And these people,
as far as I'm concerned,
are more dangerous even than
politicians.
They are,
they are put it this way.
Um,
it's the,
the Church of progress is the religion
of the,
of the emotionally defective,
the spiritually dyslexic,
and the philosophically depraved.
Or to put it into into other terms,
you actually,
martial arts master I studied with
briefly,
he used to say in his Japanese accent,
if you want,
if you want happiness in this crazy
world,
you do not talk about moon beams to the
blind or sutton or woundings to the
blind music to the death.
And you absolutely do not talk about sex
to Unix.
They just get angry.
And this is what you're dealing with
when you're dealing with these,
with these intellectually based
scientists.
These are spiritual,
emotional and philosophical unix and no
kids,
no surprise when they behave the way
they do.
Who surprised who surprised when the,
when the,
when the UNIX snigger behind the salt
back and,
and deride his passions.
The problem is that with our Church of
our church or progress,
when the Unix take over the palace and
called their terrible disability reason,
then the empire's cooked.
You sound like a person who's been
deeply in the trenches against
academics.
A bitter man.
John Anthony.
No,
I'm not bitter.
I'm just realistic and I know what's
involved from being in the trenches.
I know what's involved in fighting this
particular battle,
which I've been engaged in all of these,
all of these,
all of these decades and those are yours
cause you're dealing with archaeologists
that are trying to refute evidence.
They're all just as bad as each other.
What I bring to the table that my
colleague Graham Hancock was an
excellent writer and some of the others
who are very brilliant people.
Rupert sheldrake is all to her very good
friend and a very good scientist.
What they are not as satirists my nature
and I am
now let's go back to this idea that
human beings need to fulfill immortality
or that,
that,
that that is our ultimate destiny to
fulfill and mortality.
What?
What do you mean by that?
Exactly?
Because if there is an afterlife,
right,
if we do die and then we go to this
other place that people are seeing in
these near death experiences,
why do we have to do anything?
Why can't we just sit around and wait
for physical meet body to stop working
and then transcend?
Well,
this is again,
this gets addressed and,
and David's book and the Dead Saints
Chronicles,
um,
because it's our job to transcend.
In other words,
if we don't do anything,
well,
something happens to us.
And again,
here's where the,
the near death experiences get
interesting because almost none of them
are negative.
What happens to the real evil monster
people that are out there in this world?
I mean,
the Dick Cheney got to heaven.
They,
if he talks,
I don't want to be there.
Totally hilarious.
I'm imagining if
to having like tick fucking Cheney's up
here and you gotta be kidding me,
man.
I've done so much.
I mean,
he's in the special waterboarding.
Well,
maybe he just,
you know,
realizes it yet.
No,
but seriously,
this is the purpose.
You'd never know it from listening to
these guys.
This is the purpose of religion.
It's a,
it's a practice.
It's not something you believe in.
It's something that you do.
And if you don't do it,
you don't,
unless you go through an Nde and you
come back and you start doing it in one
way or another.
But it's my own personal conviction is
that unless enough people are doing this
and getting somewhere with it,
it's not as though everyone's going to
become enlightened.
They probably aren't gotten going to
deep into the whole theories of
reincarnation and returned and so on,
which is part of Egypt and part of this,
all of the eastern cultures,
reincarnation,
no chances are you don't make it in one
lifetime.
But these things,
let's say there's a report card,
is a divine report card where these
things are measured.
I mean Jesus says in so far heard some
in the Bible.
This is a more as a scholarly morass and
I,
I usually try to avoid using it as,
as evidenced with things because it's so
open to interpretation and it's so
convoluted to begin with and who knows
what's original to it and what isn't.
But you know,
many are called,
few are chosen,
but those who are called who do their
work or who tried to do their work
reaped the benefit of that on an
internal level that the crack epidemic
can't measure and don't want to measure
and don't believe can be measured.
But somebody with a presence is very
different from somebody without any
presence at all.
We see that in the world around you as
you go.
I want to bring you back around though
because I'm still confused.
What do you mean by it's our goal to
achieve in,
uh,
in mortality?
Like what do you mean by that?
Do you mean like the physical body no
longer dies and it,
do you believe that?
Like,
well,
whatever I read,
I do not remember what I read,
but what I read about the early,
the earliest depictions of the pharaohs
that was,
that they lived and extraordinary length
of time,
similar to like noah,
like Noah in the,
uh,
in the Bible was 600 years old when he
built the art.
Correct.
Something like that.
Um,
and that this is a,
a common thing.
And now
know is this,
because the way we think of time,
they had a different interpretation of
it and what 600 years is to us is not
600 years to them.
Is it like,
like in the Quran when they talk about
72 virgins that well you know when they
expression 72 virgins is not really 72
what that with 72 virgins means.
Well it's interesting cause it's 72
again,
what it means is a large,
it's like a shit load.
Like someone saying a shit load,
you'll have 72 virgins and having like
Whoa,
am I gonna do it all them,
you know,
it's just a,
a large number.
It's,
it's the,
the actual,
it's not,
it's not the actual number 72 it's just
sort of a euphemism for a large number.
That's one of the theories of all of
those different strange numbers in the
Bible.
And I don't know any better than anyone
else as far as I know the pharaohs lived
ordinary lifespans and of course there's
no evidence,
physical evidence of the pharaohs does
Nacho do.
And when the wine rule has ruled and
the,
I'm so hard when they ruled,
there's none of that.
And we simply don't know.
The Tibetans have accounts if you want
to believe that Tibetans and I tend to,
I don't see why they should lie of great
lamas who live several hundred years and
go when they choose to.
I don't know.
Simple as that.
And actually it's a,
it's a,
you might say it's,
uh,
it's,
it's no more than a kind of mental,
it's an interesting hypothesis like
bigfoot,
but who cares?
I'm the only thing that actually counts
as the inner work.
And if you're doing it,
you're doing it.
And if you're not doing it and you don't
measure yourself either,
as soon as you are looking for results,
that's already a way of not getting them
very,
it's a very delicate and yet profound
subject.
And she got to a good zen master.
This stuff is still around there.
There are,
there are mass.
There's my own,
my own focus as you probably know or
maybe you don't because the gird Jeff
Work of the cross when I came across
guard javelin,
extraordinary character,
he was the first person I'd ever
encountered posthumously.
He died in 49 and I found out about his
work in the 60s,
um,
who was as contemptuous of Western
civilization as I was.
The difference was that he knew how to
live in it and I didn't end at a certain
point point I figured out particularly
where you're talking about before the,
the,
the my life in the trenches.
Good subtitle for something.
I still don't understand what you mean
about achieving in mortality.
So if you're not talking about physical
inventory,
we mortality,
you're not talking about someone living
in a thousand years and plus absolutely.
What are you talking about?
You're talking about the ideas that
they,
they promote transcending and
no,
I'm talking about a level of
consciousness that transcends death.
The body dies.
And that understanding is that that
understanding is where you are.
I mean the drugs do that.
You have these moments that with the
body you come back cause he got ahead of
the trip.
Let's say it's,
it's,
it's an eternal trip.
And the ancients talk about that all the
time.
Even even in their mythology,
which it was always taken this as
fanciful,
let's say in the pyramid texts,
the,
the script reads that the,
when the Pharaoh dies and the Pharaoh
being,
let's say the embodiment of the realized
and enlightened sold.
When the Pharaoh dies,
his bar unites with his car,
his spirit unites with his essence,
becomes a star.
What star and traveled with raw across
the sky and his boat of millions of
years.
This is an in fact,
I've often wondered if the Egyptians
actually knew what he was being,
what they were talking about.
And the stars themselves are the
realizations of enlightened souls.
It's as good as any other ex explanation
that,
that there's simply balls of gas.
How did that get there?
That automatically at some point
accidentally,
um,
coalesce into galaxies and Nebula and
universes and the whole thing goes on.
Meaninglessly.
Um,
well I don't think anybody thinks it's
meaningless,
but it is kind of fascinating that stars
themselves.
So the only reason why people are alive,
we are made of stardust,
which has just where you are in deed.
Incredible to think that the seeds of
human life and all carbon life in fact
come from a star exploding like wow.
Like everything that you see,
like the sun,
the sun is a seed for future life.
That's bananas.
Exactly that.
Yeah.
Well that,
that you've answered your own question
as it were,
that,
that understanding and that,
I wouldn't even call it a philosophy,
it's an understanding by people who
understand more than we do.
Certainly more than I do,
but isn't it?
But if you say that's our goal to
achieve in mortality,
that sounds,
it sounds like we're going to get it
anyway no matter what.
Well,
no,
actually with the nds know what had I,
not really,
no,
they,
they've,
they've had their,
their experience,
they've had their x number of minutes of
grace and come back and come back
transformed and realize that they have
to live their lives differently.
They don't even talk about,
you know,
about the,
the future or anything like that.
I mean,
this is a very,
obviously a very big thing that not
many,
that not many people ever densely
achieved,
but the effort,
like everything else,
the effort is the effort and it's,
it's on the scorecard.
It's like,
it's not so different from everybody who
picks up a vial then isn't going to end
up in [inaudible] in Carnegie Hall and
everyone who picks up a baseball bat
isn't going to play center field for the
mets or any other team.
It's,
but it's the effort that counts and
it's,
it's a certain kind of directed and
intelligent effort that is painful in
its own way,
but,
but carries its own reward.
And it,
it manifests in a kind of presence and
just in our daily lives,
even with people who are not consciously
doing it,
but they're doing it,
they have a different level of presence
and you notice it when you meet them.
Hmm.
Now.
What is it that you think these ancient
Egyptians,
when you're talking about the earliest
Egyptians that you believe how to
achieve this incredible state of mind or
consciousness,
what is it that you think that they did
to achieve that?
Like why were they so advanced?
Why were they so beyond what we think of
when we think of even the possibility of
a human being living 34 plus thousand
years ago?
How did that,
how did they achieve that?
We don't know.
All we can see,
all we can see is the manifestation of
of what they did.
When we actually,
when you really understand Egypt,
even to the extent that I do you,
you,
you regarded as miraculous.
He's don't see how beings ostensibly
like ourselves should even imagine such
things much less be able to do it and
this is what I'll pitch my trip.
Okay.
I often start a lecture off by saying
that Egypt is like sex that gets
everybody's attention.
Why is it like Sachs?
Because you can read books about it and
that's inflammation.
All of sorts.
You can look at pictures.
That's a different kind or a different
level of information.
But until you've experienced it,
you,
you do not and cannot understand it.
And Egypt is like that magically,
that magical leads up series is as close
as anyone has ever come to communicating
the,
the wonder and the magic that is Egypt
as anyone has ever has ever.
It's way head and shoulders above what
anybody else has done.
And that's my genius part in their
chances doing in its entirety.
It's,
you know,
simple just ideas and I play a big role
in it,
but it's early chances baby and the,
the,
uh,
but,
but at the visit to Egypt at the end of
a couple of weeks there,
I can talk from now till Doomsday,
which I'm about in the process of doing.
Um,
and nothing,
nothing that I say,
can you come,
can come even remotely close to what
it's like to be two weeks in Egypt,
day after day after day after day in the
presence of,
of sacred art,
of this,
of this quality.
And there's nowhere else in on the left.
I mean,
I'm sure that China and India and all of
these places had not pyramids and not
that kind of structure.
The nature of Egypt,
it's strange.
It's a kind of freak of nature as it
were at all desert except this little
strip of,
of,
and then the delta that until recently
was impenetrable swamp.
So it's practically unattainable.
And the food denial floods and the food
jumps out of the ground and under the,
under the,
with,
uh,
with a series of genuinely enlightened
rulers,
or at least pretty close to enlightened
drill is ruling them.
That all lasts for 3,500
years.
And how did they live?
You see everything that they did.
In fact,
until quite recently,
there were no such things as jobs that
were trades and crafts and skills and
arts and everybody.
I mean,
yes,
and in Europe that the combination of a
repressive church and then oppressive
nobility kept everybody,
you know,
immersed in serfdom in one way or
another.
But what people actually did with that
lives was in some sense or another
transformational,
all of it.
It takes a lot of smarts to be a good
patent.
All of these things that people used to
do as a matter of course,
and in Egypt,
you see it,
you'll see it carved into the walls and
everyone thinks these are the scenes of
daily life.
While they are scenes of daily life with
the decodable as transformational
activities.
So anything that you do,
and boy,
you're doing marshal your martial arts.
This is a highly developed skill.
You will are somebody that you wouldn't
be if you were,
didn't have that scale.
If you were doing a full podcast and
what you did for a living was flipping
burgers at Mcdonald's,
you wouldn't be Joe Rogan.
You've,
you've,
you've been doing your homework without
maybe even thinking that it was
homework.
Cause any,
anything that you're involved in that,
that you go at with a quest for
perfection of whatever it is,
has this transformational value.
And when you recognize,
when you know it,
let's say,
when you know it intellectually,
when you can articulate it,
it doesn't fit,
it implements the actually the activity
itself.
So what's possible even to do that?
You could be an,
or you could be an enlightened burger
flipper and the sewer fees are very good
at,
you know,
the sophie is in life,
but not as enlarged by sorry,
is in life,
but not have it.
In other words,
you can,
you can practice waking up as it were,
uh,
in the midst of the most mundane thing
you could be.
You could,
you could be an enlightened garbage,
garbage collector as long as you knew
what you were doing.
It's a totally different thing.
I would imagine.
I'm not a cop.
It's collected.
That's a totally different thing to
collect the garbage consciously than it
is to just do it.
Resentfully because that's the only job
that they can get all the right.
So when,
when we talking,
it's,
it's not as though this is,
it's not as though this is anything
actually new.
It's is,
that's the oldest idea that ever was.
And it's something that people have been
doing for thousands and thousands of
years.
That said,
going into the whole thing of precession
and the and the and the ages,
particularly as expressed plato,
they have the golden age,
silver age,
Bronze Age,
and an iron age.
The Hindus do it and rather more
sophisticated fashion.
I forget exactly the name there on the
tip of my tongue of,
of those ages,
but if they have,
they are,
let's say analogous to our seasons,
particularly if you live where I do and
not in California where it's all one
season,
but the seasons,
the guarantees at the Yugas,
the Yugas and that's right.
It's,
it's if,
if,
if there,
compared to the seasons,
it's a very different thing to grow
roses in June than it is in January.
It's the same effort when you're talking
about the people you know,
at waking up and all of the rest of it.
This is a dark age.
I mean this is,
this is the Kali Yoga as far as I'm
concerned to do anything.
I just have a spiritual nature now with
all of these forces,
with all of these forces lined up
against you.
And not consciously of course,
but unconsciously it's,
it's an,
it's an incredibly difficult thing to
actually practice a genuine,
the genuine spiritual doctrine.
First of all,
they have to get interested in it.
And that's the only that small chunk of
it of us.
And then you have to try to do it,
and you have the time.
You have to have the folklore,
the time and the focus,
the,
that's right.
The focus and the weld and all the rest
of the things and that.
So that's,
so growing roses in January takes a lot
more effort than to get to the same rows
than it takes in June when the jumping
out of the ground.
So my guess is,
and it's only gas,
it's speculation that in these higher
levels of these higher periods of,
of know Golden,
silver,
bronze and so on,
it's just much easier.
It is much easier for people to
recognize what's demanded of them and to
do it than it is in the middle of,
uh,
of,
from a spiritual point of view of
spiritual but brightly lit,
brightly an illuminated but brightly
lit,
dark,
dark age.
Well,
if you,
where we are,
if you look at the influence that Egypt
had clearly on Greece and clearly on a
lot of other civilizations where people
literally came to Egypt to learn,
if each app wasn't there,
what would civilization be like?
I mean,
it's such a unique place in that
there's,
there's really no where that you can
compare that has the level of
sophistication as far as the structures
and the ancient in the ancient world has
not even,
I mean,
it's almost like they're,
what they created was undeniable.
Hmm.
Like,
I think Giza,
the Great Pyramid of Giza as 2 million,
300,000
stones,
they way between two and 80 tons.
Like what?
Like how that's insane.
Like the,
there's the level of sophistication and
creating something like that.
I mean,
I've only seen it in photographs,
but one of the greatest photographs I've
ever seen is from someone with a gopro
standing on the top of it.
So you get this kind of a,
you get a sense of how immense it
really,
truly is.
Yeah.
And you just think about how,
how incredible that must have been when,
especially when it's covered with smooth
limestone in four,
they cut it all off.
I mean,
what,
what you're seeing is it's,
it's an undeniable mastery of physical
things to the point where you just,
it makes you just,
it makes your head spin because we,
I mean,
people say we can do that today.
Well,
okay,
maybe we kind of understand that it's
been done and that we,
we can do pretty immense things.
We have some pretty incredible tractors
and machines and everything like that.
But they didn't have those.
No.
As far as we know,
they didn't have those.
They might've had something else.
What do you think they had?
I don't know.
I mean,
do you think about,
do just,
do you have like some hypothesis,
some theories in your head about the
construction methods?
Some a bit that,
that actually from Tibet.
There's actually a funny little book
I've done some lectures at,
at uh,
um,
what is it called,
in Joshua tree,
you know,
about that event?
Um,
it's a contact in the desert.
They're mostly interested in the UFO
phenomenon and stuff like that.
But the place itself,
Joshua retreat center is founded by a
very interesting guy who was sort of the
Tibetan Krishnamurti.
In other words,
it's an interesting little book he wrote
and terribly written,
but his,
his studies in Tibet.
And at the end of his little book he's
talking about,
he studying with the,
with the llamas he just described
certain of the certain of the things he
has seen them do.
And I see no particular reason to
dismiss what he says.
He's talking from experience and it has
the ring of veracity to it.
And he talks about,
um,
going into an underground chamber that
has no lights or electricity or anything
like that.
That's all lit up.
And actually go to Egypt.
We have these deep,
deep shaft tombs that go down and around
and all like this.
And people say,
well,
how did they light the thing up?
Can't have had torches or would have,
it would have used up all of the oxygen
and it would have smoked up the ceilings
and all the rest of it.
When people say,
well mirrors,
no mirrors will do and then you need
silvered mirror is for that to go around
corners there other gypsy caves in
Seville that are four or five rooms in
that are lit with mirrors from on top.
But no,
somehow,
and I used to joke and say,
well you know,
they had an inner light and joking but
maybe that's what,
maybe that's what it was.
But the producers and talks about other
Lama's,
these witness doing incredible feats of
that you couldn't do,
you know that you just couldn't do in
your ordinary state.
Probably you as a martial artist,
I've had moments or witnessed people who
can do things that are for anybody else.
Impossible.
Yeah,
but they don't light up tunnel snow.
They don't light up tunnel.
But,
but they can do,
they can do physical things that,
that are,
they're extraordinary.
They're almost miraculous that nobody
else could do them.
Yeah.
But that,
that's a,
it's a really important point where
you're saying about the construction
methods that they used where they did
have these long tunnels and these
passages and these places,
but somehow or another,
they managed to navigate these things
without leaving any marks or soot from,
from torches,
which are everywhere else where people
use candles or anywhere else.
Like,
you know,
you didn't the Sistine Chapel,
like the entire ceiling was covered with
some,
you know,
they had to clean it,
to prepare it so people could see it
again.
But that's,
um,
that's really fascinating to think that
they had some other method of
illumination that we just haven't
discovered yet.
We don't know what they did or how they
did it.
That's one thing.
But you look at a jillion other things
when you particularly,
this is again,
one of the reasons why the swinks theory
is,
is so is so contentious to these,
so dangerous to these guys because the
swings,
carving the spanx is one thing,
but okay,
limestones are relatively resilient
stones.
Are you relatively soft stone enough?
Guys with chisels,
even if they're copper chiseled could do
that given enough time and enough
genius.
But the temple die the side of it,
um,
and are built of stones half the size of
this room slotted into place like pieces
of a jigsaw puzzle.
This is unbelievable.
And again,
what you just said is really important.
Copper,
copper tools,
that's what they think.
Copper tempered with arsenic.
I mean that.
But those same copper tools to
supposedly are supposedly used for,
for carving the granite,
the,
if you go to Egypt actually usually get
you a huge audience.
Got to Juggle Rogan,
trip together and come on to people
listening to this podcast.
We'll have a test.
Too many fruits,
well 90% of them would be great to 10%
will keep out the 10%.
It's just do it,
do it.
Prepare,
filter.
Okay.
Conversation with them.
Prepare a filter,
get them in a room,
prepare a filter.
And how many people when you taking the
time?
I have a Max of 24 hmm.
Interesting.
It's not more than that is an
unmanageable.
And when you see it,
I mean one thing after the other and
it's totally safe to go to Egypt.
Narcan right now.
Well,
it's a safe as Los Angeles.
I mean,
we were anywhere else here and then
didn't Dumbfuckistan it's,
you know,
this is tough work for Americans.
We're Americans too,
of all people to be afraid of going
somewhere.
We're worried about Islamic terrorism
more than anything because we then,
it's here.
It's already here.
And Islamic terrorism is itself a tiny
little bit of the terrorism that goes on
on a daily basis.
You pick up that you opened the internet
and there's some nutcase kid somewhere
or another shooting down a mall.
I mean,
the terrorist,
the known terrorists have accounted for.
It's not even the statistic,
it's an x number of people that they've
gone after.
But you know,
here,
here in this crazy violent country,
you'll never safe anywhere.
Schools aren't safe,
malls aren't safe.
What's safe,
right.
So Kira has some nice hotels too,
right?
Oh Great.
Hotels.
Yeah.
We stay at a place to actually right
across a stone's throw from the pyramids
itself.
So you can look at the pyramid out your
window.
Yeah.
You can't do that.
Oh boy.
When I look at,
uh,
the Great Pyramid are,
I look at the,
uh,
the structure that I've seen online or
in your videos or things along those
lines.
What's shocking to me is how each,
and this is going to be a weird thing to
say how Egyptian it looks and how Egypt
stands alone in this very distinctive
way and that the,
the construction methods,
the,
that just the intricacy of the building
and these pyramids,
I mean,
people talk about the Mayan Pyramids and
I've been to [inaudible] needs and it's
an amazing place and it's really
beautiful and crazy to look at,
but it pales in comparison to the
structures of Egypt.
Yeah.
Everything pales in comparison with it.
How did that happen?
Well as I said,
because it was in a kind of a blessing
lung.
It had,
it had a philosophy,
you know,
it had a spiritual philosophy
underpinning it that had the,
that had the,
that that had,
you might say that had the,
that united the people in their entirety
doesn't mean that they weren't,
you know,
criminals and murderers and stuff like
that.
But basically the people were united in
their,
in their faith and delighted in their
belief errata this when Egypt was sixth
century BC,
the rod is this,
and Egypt is already in steep decline as
the Egyptians of the happiest,
healthiest,
and most religious of people.
That wasn't the Egyptian Chamber of
Commerce that was telling him to say
that he was a patriotic Greek,
but it was like that.
And it was a combination of the
philosophy wedded to it in a,
in a society that was protected on all
four sides and almost an almost
impregnable.
It was conquered a couple of times over
the course of 3000 years for a
relatively brief period of time,
um,
and the food jumped out of the ground.
The Nile flooded and took practically no
work and that I made a a quite
substantial population but gave them
months of free time every,
every year.
And so how did it all go wrong?
That would,
talking about the colleague Ogas,
um,
the whatever that whatever period Egypt
is assigned to is on a downhill slope.
It just plain was on a downhill slope
and you can,
you can watch it transform in front of
your eyes.
It,
it disintegrates as a coherent religion
rises in another form that we call
Christianity actually,
and could see it happening in front of
your nose with Coptic Christianity
arising.
All the rest of the stuff gets
completely decadent under the Romans and
syndrome.
What's his name?
Gibbon.
And we'd given in decline and fall of
the Roman empire,
talks about the grand jury,
the glory of Greece,
which is absolute nonsense or totally
with near total nonsense.
And the Grand Juror Rome.
Yeah.
They were building coliseums and elected
and wanted to torture in order to let
die gladiators kill each other.
And they built good roads.
But Ron was a three ring bro,
three ring bureaucracy actually.
And that's the beginning of the end.
And Europe anyway,
it's very traceable.
The the Asian countries less so,
but they too have high civilizations
that decline.
And in Europe you see kind of a
turnaround in the renaissance,
the very impossible to actually date.
And then you have it leading in a sort
of,
in a one very one sided development in
which in which technology advances by
leaps and bounds and everything else is
arguably a lot worse than it was a
couple of hundred years ago from us.
From every spiritual psychological point
of view,
we are a lot worse off than let's say
the colonial American.
Yeah.
Steve really thinks so.
The depictions of the colonial Americans
by,
um,
by the ancient people.
When,
when,
when you,
uh,
who was it that described the atrocities
that Columbus and his crude had done?
Um,
what preacher?
Priest,
no,
loads of the mature,
horrific,
horrific things.
Those are the conquerors.
Yeah.
We're not talking about the settlers and
the Indians.
Right.
Oh,
and the other,
this already pulled that stuff.
Montezuma was a piece of shit.
Blotter of 80,000
slaves after they built Tia to con.
How he say that.
Te Te,
te Lacan Teal,
teal con this I don't,
this I don't know about and I don't know
again,
but they say my bad people to loads of
bad people that just didn't have the
Internet
talking about it.
They certainly didn't have the Internet
and lots of other goodies.
They didn't have.
Um,
no,
but that was a certain,
let's say about the populous in general
in America.
A certain gravitas about them.
There's a certain presence that is of
our great,
great grandfathers,
well not mine cause they were in Hungary
at that time.
My great,
great.
But there's a certain,
okay,
sort of,
it's like Emerson self reliance.
I mean this is,
this is a piece of her I meanwhile of
course the weapon,
all the slaves in the south and they're
murdering all the Indians and the,
and the billionaires as is their fashion
or beating up on their Irish immigrant
workers.
That's why perhaps slaves when they can
mistreat their,
their work is in build there,
you know,
and build all of their,
uh,
their railroads across the country.
But nevertheless,
there's a sense of,
they say Grub a test is almost the only
word I can think of.
Cause it's not as though it's
intellectually advanced or anything like
that,
but there's a certain seeming solidity
to 19th century America then than there
is now in this crazy chaos.
Don't you think that there's always this
tendency in human beings that long from
front Ostalgie they look back to the
past to a moment when things made sense.
It seems to me that there's always that.
And even when people are full of shit
about it,
like they look back in high school days,
man,
those were the good old days.
Like what are you talking about yet?
Pimples,
you were out of your fucking mind and
secure.
You're terrified of the future.
That wasn't the good old days.
It's true.
Yeah.
Trump make America great again.
Yeah,
bring back slavery.
Find some more.
Until we run out of Indians.
Murder The let's,
let's go to the Arab nations or let's go
out in the Amazon.
Yeah,
hell,
let's import them and murder and let's
bring back all of that stuff.
No,
it was never great.
But as I said,
there's just,
there is a kind of,
maybe I'm more optimistic.
I think there's an awakening going on
right now with human beings that's
unprecedented and I think it's because
of the Internet.
I think because of the fact that we're
combining our thoughts and some sort of
a strange way and sharing ideas and
information in a way that no one's ever
been able to do before.
I just,
I don't think people who've ever been
this aware of how crazy things are.
Uh,
but at the same time it's lifted the
lunacy of last night's presidential
debate and you realize like,
well I guess we really haven't,
I mean we might be aware of things but
actual progress and not really being
made.
We,
we have the ability to be aware of
things.
Yes.
But we are not,
we are not at least in sufficient
numbers.
Okay.
Doing anything like we are,
we are not doing anything about it.
And that's the crux of the matter.
It's one thing.
This is why intellectual spiritual,
intellectual mysticism is a total waste
of time.
Only the,
it's like intellectual violin playing.
No,
he got to play the violin or it's not
music.
Right.
So,
so thinking about Egypt is not great.
The ability,
well that,
yes.
The ability to
yeah.
To,
to get information is now absolutely
unparalleled.
Yeah.
There's,
there's no,
as far as we know,
there's never been anything remotely
like this.
If the same time there's never been that
much static.
So it was,
hey we were talking about earlier the,
you know the,
the crystals sniffers in the Unicorns
and the ancient aliens.
This is,
this is all a vast amount of static.
So you have to be able to find a way
that you have to find your way through
the static to the music.
How much is ancient aliens frustrated?
Yeah.
Cause as much,
cause I know I watched a couple of
programs did,
he's throwing things at the TV and I
have low expectations.
So it's TV.
It's supposed to,
it's entertainment than the people who
are putting it together.
You know,
don't know what they're doing except
they see that it works.
Then they want to make money.
Is it possible that he
aliens made the Pyramids?
I want to have all these experts.
Everything in is,
is it possible?
That extra terrestrials I guess that's
possible.
Yeah.
Through I will.
It is possible.
And Georgia of course pushed into a
corner says yeah,
all of this and that and so on.
Still it's aliens.
Georgia.
So close.
Yeah.
He's,
he's beautiful.
I love that guy.
He's a funny guy.
Um,
w when you think of ancient Egypt and
you,
you think of the,
the public's understanding and awareness
of it,
what do you think the average person is
missing?
All of it.
All of it,
basically.
Yeah.
So you think it's like right before our
fate in front of our eyes and most
people just have no idea the majesty and
how intensely unique it is.
Oh,
look,
our mystery of the Spanx,
which at that time,
one of the most,
one of the most watched TV documentaries
of all time,
and I really had a massive audience and
people who saw it,
remember it?
I mean,
even to this day,
um,
you saw it.
Oh,
you did?
Okay.
I have a vhs cassette tape of it serve
really late.
I brought it.
Wait,
did I bring it?
I'd forget if I brought you the way I'm
gonna get it online now.
Might be on youth on DVD.
I was going to bring you a DVD of it
actually,
but I've maybe for kind of almost
memorized it.
Well,
that's good.
And I've seen anyway quite a few times
that had a certain impact for sure.
Even if 30 million people saw it,
300 minutes didn't,
right.
And then going there,
it's really what's up and well that's
the,
that's that's the big crunch.
And that only x number of people can go
there.
I went to the Vatican last summer.
Yeah.
This past summer.
Um,
my first time ever in Italy.
And uh,
I had seen it on television before.
Obviously I'd seen videos and stuff.
I've seen photos.
Boy,
when you're there and you're,
you're like,
what does it,
St Peter's Basilica.
St Paul's.
Saint Paul's.
No,
Paul's St Paul's.
Wait,
one of those guys.
And now Miss [inaudible] at Saint
Peter's is okay.
It is with the Dome,
with a Buffalo.
It comes out.
Yeah.
And you,
you look at it and you go when you're
inside of it and you realize the insane
magnitude of the construction,
the fact that it took hundreds of years
to complete and they did it all without
sauce,
without power tools,
rather.
They did it all without any modern
equipment and unbelievably beautiful,
incredible work of art.
And it pales in comparison to what they
did in Egypt.
Yes,
it does.
Which is like it.
There's certain,
I think I got to go because it's one of
those,
well,
they also have an obelisk that's a 4,000
year old ambulance.
I said a little major.
Yeah,
they stole it from me.
And you just look at that and when
you're there physically and you look at
it in person,
you just go,
how long fuck did they make this?
Wait a minute now wait,
this is,
yeah,
cathedral is the silica is very
interesting and all that.
But how did they move?
How did they get this actually
interesting book by my now deceased
friend Peter Tompkins on the magic of
the obelisks where he's talking about,
you know,
ripping that out of there.
Out of context and bringing him to Rome
and New York and New England,
and it was interesting because they were
brought over in the 19th century and
it's already,
you know,
technology's pretty advanced.
I mean was huge cranes and all the rest
of it and it strained the,
the Victorian technology to the utmost.
They get these things over and then you
realize that the Egyptians did it with
none of those tools that all they
somehow got ripped out of the bedrock,
brought down the river,
taken offloaded from the raft or boats
or whatever,
but there's a big job transported across
the ground that's doable,
erected in place precisely to the
millimeter millimeter on the base.
That's a big mystery.
They have levels.
What did they have levels like bubble
levels and not bubbled levels,
but they had other kinds of did it with
water somehow or another that that's,
that's I think reasonably well
established,
but I forget exactly how it was on how
they leveled.
For example,
the base of the pyramid to the
millimeter or something like that.
I mean everything that you look at in
Egypt,
when you go there,
the deeper you look,
the more mysterious it becomes and new
marvel at on.
The devil did this.
Well,
the king's chamber is one of the most
bizarre ones.
Well no buzz up.
More bizarre than than other things.
I mean it's a,
but just the enormity of the stones,
the way theirs,
they're set up that it's just,
it's such a complex system.
The way that the way they've set them in
place is so cool.
You're talking about the ones that the,
the so called relieving chambers,
which are really resonating.
Chambers,
resonating chambers.
Yeah,
that,
that's another thing I think.
Yeah,
they're not that.
They don't really,
they don't relieve anything
architectural.
He completely unnecessary to relieve
the,
the stresses from above directly below
the king chamber is the so called
Queen's chamber,
which doesn't have that at all,
has a simple gabled roof and that
protects it from anything that it needs.
The other Chambers,
when you're in the king chamber,
it's like being,
it's an echo chamber.
You can't.
It's,
it's really a miraculous place and of
course everything is precision cotton,
all of that,
but it doesn't look that fantastic
insistent and it's the,
the level above that are the most
amazing things because these are the 70
ton blocks of stone.
I think that's where you're talking
about how they got those into place.
No one knows,
but they're responsible for the
resonance of that,
of that particular chamber.
And it's my belief that resonance plays
even not necessarily resonance with the
human voice,
but when you're in there,
the the,
I forget the acoustic term feedback or
whatever that you can't.
For example,
if we're in the king's chamber and we
go,
we rent the pyramid for a couple of
hours in for a meditation session and
not on my trips,
and when you're in there,
you can't have a conversation the way
we're having it now you have to talk
like this.
Otherwise the reverberation is such that
it's grumbled your voice.
Well,
if this can only be deliberate and you
can hear from the,
you can hear from the king's chamber.
If you do set up and you do a chant in
the king's chamber,
if you go all the way down the ground
gallery,
and then there's a place below where you
have to make a turn.
And then there's a descending passage
that goes as deep below the ground as
the,
as the pyramid has this king's chamber
is above the ground is about 12 story
shaft that you go out on the ground,
12 stories,
12 stories down below and then 12
stories built.
Wow.
Good luck.
And I'll write a very good and um,
and I,
uh,
and,
and if you set up a chance in the,
in the king's chamber,
you can hear it down in the,
in the pit below 12 stores below.
Yeah.
But you shouldn't be able to hear it at
all because the sound has to go down and
then turn around and then go down the
other shop.
By the way,
I should say,
because people are always asking me,
now,
it's a function of age.
How long are you going to keep doing
these traps?
And I say,
well,
you know,
unless and until,
um,
I can't get up and down the king time up
to the king's chamber,
I'll,
I'll be doing trips unless some media
thing takes over.
But they say in Texas,
if you can do it,
it ain't bragging.
Good line.
So I was in Egypt reasonably on my,
on the research reckie trip,
but that may lead to something and the
May not,
we'll say keep trip or record
reconnaissance.
Oh,
the film Lingo for reconnaissance.
I thought it was like,
no,
not regular,
not reiki now and,
and actually,
so normally you have a go with the group
up to the king's chamber.
But I don't bother to go.
We open,
it gets opened up and he'd go down into
the pet side,
said Nah,
cause my,
on my 84th birthday I happened to be in
Egypt.
So I said,
okay,
well I'll test it.
So I went up to the king's chamber and
down the shaft,
that's 12 stories up on 12 stories down
and I went down to the pit.
It was 12 stories down and 12 stories up
and I figured that was pretty good for
her,
so it was pretty good.
Um,
so I'll be doing the trips for a while.
Nice.
Well that's good because I mean,
I don't think anybody's capable of doing
the same kind of experience that you
would provide.
Like your knowledge of Egypt is,
it's pretty rare in this day and age.
Well,
I was hoping when I had this idea to
dude my own trips,
I thought,
oh finally I'll make a living out of
this stuff.
But what happened was that no sooner had
my guidebook come out.
You probably don't have a copy of that,
but it's out of print now.
But I have copies,
um,
that um,
back in [inaudible] 85,
the first of the terrorist things happen
then these guys hijack the cruise ship
off Alexandria and push this poor old
guy in a wheelchair over the side of the
crowd of the cruise ship and he drowned.
And that my book had just come out and
instantly the tourist trade was killed.
It's talking about people being afraid
for a whole year.
It took for it to develop and it,
it did develop again,
but the book had disappeared from the
shelves by that time anyway.
Was still available of course.
But um,
wait,
I lost my thread.
Um,
with the trips.
Like what did you say with Egypt?
Someone doing what?
Someone doing it.
My plan was I wanted to train a number
of people up to who cook familiar,
you know,
steeped and symbol as Egypt to to spread
the word as it were.
And while I'm,
while I was added,
get a commission from,
from the trips to,
you know,
provide some useful wolf repellent so
you can have some nice passive income
sometimes.
Right.
But it never happened because you know,
one thing led to another and it was hard
enough getting my own trips filled up.
But yeah,
the PR,
but unfortunately as it now stands,
I'm the only one,
only a handful of people know symbolist
Egypt well enough to communicate it as
it just so happens I'm the only one who
does trips out.
I really,
I really am the only wheel in town in
that regard.
Well,
you brought us a bunch of slides,
so once you tell me what,
what,
what do you want to show us and what did
you bring here?
Well,
I brought,
that's my whole long lecture.
You want to see,
you want to go to the,
to the geology of the Sphinx,
the water weathering.
Um,
and then the other slides,
um,
related to that,
the gigantic blocks paving blocks,
um,
around particularly around the second
pyramid.
And I'm,
and I'm fucking pyramid and yeah,
mostly around the second pyramid.
And then I mean all of that stuff
relates to the scientific,
the geological evidence.
Then I wanted to get into,
I didn't want to touch the,
the symbolist,
the quest for immortality cause that's a
total big subsequent thing I did want to
get into and we didn't even talk about
it.
Um,
yeah,
the map of the map of Dumbfuckistan and,
and what I call the,
the,
and I've got a great graphic for it.
And actually the everybody,
you know,
certainly and everybody,
probably most of your audience will know
about the four horsemen of the
apocalypse,
right.
From revelation who are actually
interesting study in its own right.
The four horsemen are war,
famine and war,
famine,
pestilence,
and death.
And what's interesting about the four
horsemen is that only war is really
under human control,
at least in theory,
the famine,
pestilence,
plague,
as it were,
and death comes to us all.
It's a peculiar choice actually for the
four horsemen.
But I invented the five cowboys of
apocalypse 2.0
and they are,
and they are capitalism,
patriotism,
democracy,
technology and entertainment.
All this stuff I love.
Yeah.
Well that's the end.
Well,
no,
it's just another way of looking at
things actually.
And it's really human folly.
All of it,
right?
Well,
yeah,
call it democracy.
Call it capitalism,
call it technology.
It's,
it's none of those things.
It's human folly.
It's the human,
the error and human use that,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
okay.
Capitalism is really based upon the
philosophy.
Everything for me,
nothing for you.
You see everybody's fighting for market
share.
Why can't you live with a guide?
Stay alive.
It wasn't,
that's competition.
But if it wasn't for that competition,
we wouldn't be here.
It shoot across the sky wouldn't have
laptops at work so well we might have
internet that's so fast.
I don't know and we might,
but we might not.
It's very possible that we wouldn't and
there's a downside to all of those
things,
but the mat upside too.
There isn't.
I'm a glass half full kind of guy.
That to me was that's the technology
side of it and got to that yet totalism
is based upon everything for me.
Nothing for you.
Patriotism is based upon everything for
us.
Nothing for them.
The bumper sticker says God bless
America,
but hidden sticky sides as in fuck
everyone else,
right?
That's patriotism.
Democracy is that the idea is that the
dishwashers elect the chef and tell them
what to do.
I don't know about you.
I don't eat in the restaurant with the
dishwashers,
elect the chef and tell him what to do.
It's flawed.
It's hopelessly flawed to begin with,
which Plato recognized perfectly.
Churchill said,
deb malick cracy looks like the worst of
all possible of all possible political
systems until look at all the others
at the same time.
This is fun and it's not necessarily
untrue.
The same time.
He also said contradicting himself.
The best argument against democracy is
10 minutes of conversation with an
average voter.
I know about you.
I don't want my leaders elected
numerically ply.
The average voter actually,
if they had a test for,
if there were,
which is next to impossible to even
conceive if it,
if,
if voting we're a privilege.
I mean when the country started off it
was a privilege,
but you had to be a white male who owned
property,
which is not as elitist as it actually
looks now because in those days they
were the only ones who were substantial
enough and probably had some sort of an
education.
It doesn't mean necessarily that they
understand the principles and they,
you know,
they,
they were the s you might say this solid
citizens who at least could read,
I mean,
nobody else could read except people
with an education of some sorts.
So that was,
that was the rule and it wasn't a
terribly good rule,
but it might have been in its own way
anyway.
That's as a principle that it shouldn't
be a privilege to vote just as like
anybody could produce pr.
Why shouldn't anybody be able to do
brain surgery,
you know,
or design engineer design a bridge.
I'm as good as the next guy but I'm
never designed to bridge.
I don't have any training,
but it's a democracy.
Why can't I do that?
Or play center field for the mets that I
would just really essentially anybody,
you just have to say,
I want to do it,
step up.
This is my plan and get people to vote
for you.
Well that it's a catastrophe anyway,
put it this way and its current form and
in fact as far back as he could go in
America,
it's been a disaster.
Democracy technology is certainly a
mixed bag.
The problem.
Two big problems with technology.
The main one,
and we touched upon this earlier,
is that technology deprives the average,
the normal human being of making a
living out of his own product,
out of his own creativity.
It deprives them.
Technology does it.
The only people who are creative in
technology are the people who are
creating the technology.
Everybody else serves the technology.
They work in the offices that serve the
technology.
They they,
they're basically slaves to the
technology.
What about the people that use the
technology to separate themselves from,
from slave jobs?
Like there's a lot of people that have
started their own businesses online.
Yeah,
because they could use technology now,
so you can crafts people,
create things.
That's the upside,
but it's a relatively small part
compared to the number of people they
talk about.
They talk about all these good jobs
going at the China.
That was a shitty jobs.
Nobody in their right mind would to work
in a factory.
If you ever worked in a factory,
no.
Or been in the factory.
Really.
I've been in factories.
I went to schools is seldom as I
possibly could in Bethlehem,
Pennsylvania,
which is where the,
the,
uh,
Bethlehem steel center was.
And we used to go there on field drops.
Holy Mackerel.
These,
this was like working in Dante's
inferno,
these black and figured jumping up and
down in the blind,
the heat of the bessemer converters and
the other kinds of jobs of robots
stuffing things into boxes of flipping
burgers.
The vast majority of people,
yeah,
they got the,
that,
you know,
they have the television sets and their
internet and stuff like that.
But,
but the vast majority of people cannot
do not and cannot make their living out
of their own creativity.
And before,
however terrible things may have been in
medieval times,
people did creative transformational
things.
Cause that's the downside of technology
and the other bad side of technology,
you talked about the good side,
the bad side is that it's,
it's not immoral necessarily,
but it's amoral.
So as long as they can do it,
they do it.
Um,
within my budget.
Well,
hydrogen bomb,
why not?
We don't invent it.
Somebody else will do it.
Nerve gas.
Well that's a very good way of getting
wet roadway with,
you know,
around stuff,
strike toothpaste.
Well it's a waste of time and effort and
stuff like that,
but maybe we can sell more,
strike two strike toothpaste,
then unstrapped toothpaste and the rest
of it is,
in other words,
a percentage of it.
Yeah,
the medicine is very good until it gets
into the hands of big Pharma that makes
sure that the most,
that that,
that,
that people are ripped off for her to
get at the medicine that they need in
the medicine that they,
that they have available is not usually
a cure.
It's a way of keeping people alive and
buying more medicine.
Anything that's actually a cure that
comes from alternative sources is fought
to the death by,
by the big pharmaceutical companies.
So technology is certainly a mixed bag
and entertainment,
depending on how you define it,
is what,
what you do to kill time before it kills
you.
For the most part,
it's a waste of,
it's an absolute waste of time.
It's takes your mind off the,
of the boringness of your own life.
Um,
artists,
different art is not entertainment.
There's a broad,
there's a broad line in between that at
least in theory,
could or should be filled by comedy,
which is not exactly entertainment,
but it's not exactly sacred science
either,
but it plays at least theoretically it,
it,
it can play a kind of a transformational
role.
You can,
real high level comedy is enlightening.
It's,
it,
it points out and comedy is based upon,
you can't laugh.
You can only,
comedy is based upon what's wrong.
You can't laugh at what's right.
You can't make fun of good sex or good
food and you can make fun of attitudes
toward good sex or good food.
But you can't laugh.
That's at what's right.
Not Easily,
but you can laugh,
but you can do laugh at what's wrong.
And so let's say at some inner level by
laughing at what's wrong
inadvertently,
it's a recognition we have within us,
let's say a moral,
uh,
we have a moral,
okay,
compass by the wrong word.
We have a moral thermometer or something
of the sort that recognizes by
recognizing what's wrong were assenting
we're giving asset to what's right.
It is too cultural.
Of course.
What's funny to an Eskimo is not
necessarily funny to an African,
the 22 an African is not necessarily
funny to work,
you know,
to a Chinese,
but comedy has this potential to play,
at least in my view,
a transformational role.
But anyway,
mostly it doesn't,
an entertainment at the American level
turn on your television set is that
entertain and it's certainly not art.
It's,
it's,
it's a deadening.
It's an anodyne.
It's,
it's sort of,
most of it is,
is,
is a,
is a kind of,
um,
what's,
what's it take to go set it?
It's,
it is a,
it's basically a kind of sedative or the
opposite or,
uh,
it's like a benny,
it's a stimulant that it's an,
it's a stimulant,
right?
Actually with your opens the terminator
and all of that horrible,
vicious things that they do.
So that's,
yeah.
Let's get to the slides,
right?
It's cause we're already two hours in
here.
No,
yeah.
Let's,
um,
let's take a look at some of the slides
of a,
what do you want to start?
Let's start with the geology start right
at the beginning and I'll just whip your
passed.
Okay,
now why are they,
this is a really confusing thing to me.
Why do they continue to rebuild that
thing?
Because when they're rebuilding it and
they're rebuilding the feet and the
pause of the Sphinx,
and I understand there's considerable
erosion that that they have to mitigate,
but it's not the sphinx anymore.
I mean it's bringing the swings back to
supposedly what it was originally.
The problem is really is an engineering
problem.
They don't know themselves and at least
a few of them acknowledge it.
Shock,
thanks this number and he's done.
He's not in charge of doing the repairs
that it may be doing more damage because
it's still weathering on the inside and
like covering it over with these usually
very badly,
badly done stuff,
but they're actually doing more damage
than that.
Well,
the Department of Antiquities,
is that what you're no longer,
he's no longer in the bucky.
Did they lock them up?
No,
no,
no.
He was in trouble.
Well,
he was in trouble,
but they couldn't it on it.
They could.
Now listen,
I,
on a personal level,
that's another long story when we were
already gone on for two hours,
but on a personal level,
I can get on with Zady and a nine,
he's now back in,
not formally in a position of power is
not headed the department and he,
because he's got his problems.
Do you see the debate that he had with
Graham Hancock?
God,
he was,
yeah,
he was exactly there.
And,
and all of his friends even,
I mean,
the guy who runs my trip Mama dogs
meeting,
I called the surgeon because he really
knows how to operate his wonderful guy
and he's a good personal friend of Zeiss
and he said,
you know,
thought he,
this is a disaster,
but he,
you know,
he lived through it and he's back back
on the scene as it were.
Anyway,
we're looking at this finks and closure
here and a,
this massive,
massive structure with this,
all this erosion around it,
right?
All this road intuit and then they'll
send this on youtube.
Um,
yeah.
When,
when you'll see as we go through a few
sides,
you get a few slides,
you'll see the sense of that erosion.
This is just a wonderful picture of it
taken by a good friend of mine.
Keep going about,
this is why,
this is why the swings could not have
been weathered by sand.
What we're looking at right now for the
people that are just listening,
is it buried in sand,
which it has been many,
many times when,
um,
when Napoleon found that it was burdened
sand correct,
completely buried in sand and probably
for a few thousand years,
this is taken photograph taken about
2000 when it had already been excavated
and filled up with sand again,
which happens pretty quickly.
So basically you can say,
give a take a few hundred years that
since it's supposed did construction
around 2,500
BC,
it's been buried in sand about 3000 of
those 4,500
years.
That's the proof.
Yeah,
that's,
there's the evidence and still the
geologists go on ranting about sand.
When you were talking about this friend
of yours is going to cause a dreezy.
Okay.
How did it,
how did it,
whether by sand,
wind and sand,
right.
The wind can't get the wind,
can't it?
The fact that that way,
it wasn't that the original text of
whoever who,
who do they attribute to?
The construction of the pyramid?
Moses?
No,
no,
no.
Pharaoh Khafra cops.
This successor of Khufu who supposedly
built the Great Pyramid,
which is not true in its entirety,
the pyramids.
This is another comp com complex
argument,
which means you see everything's
complex.
They're almost certainly built in stages
in the earliest stages,
probably date from whenever the Sphinx
was originally built and the argument
for coffer building.
It wasn't a tax that said that he had a
dream that if he uncovered this,
thinks that he would become pharaoh.
No,
that's took Moses.
That's torn fat.
A thousand years later they attributed
to compro because the causeway that
leads from the spanx.
If you'd go to the behind it cause
either the beginning,
not really as he just back into spanx.
The causeway,
the causeway leads up to the right to
the middle of the PR of the Pyramid of
the car for up pyramid,
which he almost certainly did build or
any way super imposed upon something
that was there before because you can
prove that.
Okay,
keep going to use the thing it was
taught Moses was that,
no,
no.
They always thought it was,
they always thought it was [inaudible]
because uh,
well that again,
what is this right here?
That's not the Rosetta stone is no,
no,
no.
That's the,
that's the Stele of took Moses that
talks about how in a dream he ate,
it's covered with sand.
Oh that's everyday.
That's the end.
1450 BC.
So as Abbott in 1450 BC,
it was confidence and exactly with a
certain number of other evidences of
that sort,
you can put together the timeline that
tells you,
I swear I've read online someone
attributed and Tut Moses to the creation
of it,
but there's a lot of,
a lot of junk.
Now the face of this finks and this is a
really controversial thing,
right,
because the face of the Sphinx is
clearly newer than the body.
It's less eroded and it's also a very
African looking face.
Do they think that,
which is obviously it's the continent
Africa,
but did they think there's the new beans
had conquered Egypt at one point in
time,
right?
It wasn't the speculation that one of
the new being farrows had,
uh,
created this,
well,
some said that 19th century travelers,
lots of them noted that this was really
an African face.
But what they meant is that it's a sub
Sahara Africa.
It's a real African African face.
The new means a very black but have more
or less find her features.
They don't have to draw like that.
I mean that looks more like an NBA
basketball player,
Egyptian,
right?
Like the head dresses all re redone the
picture before with covered with sand.
You see how they do read it.
The bottom had bets in,
in its entirety.
The face itself is a much harder outcrop
of limestone.
So it hasn't weathered to the same
extent that the body of the Sphinx has
weathered.
So you think it's the same era?
We don't know actually we of it,
you see the,
the African face is a,
is a real problem actually.
Of course the Egyptians,
there was prejudice does everyone else
and they don't want to actually believe
that the Sphinx itself could be a sub
Saharan African.
Maybe from an earlier period when the
Africans were pharaoh's we don't know.
Wasn't there some speculation that
initially it was an actual lion's face
and that the lion's face was cut down to
create this,
that that's us speculating that way
because the head is way too small for
the body and it's certainly,
and we had the NYP D we did this big
study.
I think that's the next slide coming up.
Um,
yeah,
there it is that you see the,
with Frank Domingo who was the,
um,
and why can't you taste well he was a
forensic senior forensic artist for the
NYP D is a guy who knows
about physiology so young,
young.
So he did a study of the comparative
phases of the swings.
And the of the strengths,
that's the one on the right and feral
conference.
And his conclusion was that no artists,
no competent artist or sculptor who
could possibly have used the same model
for the face of the spanx.
As for the cop rock face,
right?
Professing there's a few Kopra faces
floating around.
So the,
my criminal partner,
when frank gave us that study,
um,
his,
his comparative study,
Boris Saeed said,
ah,
for the,
for the academic establishment,
this is bad news and worse news,
the bad news is that there wasn't
Atlantis.
And the worst news is they were black.
My black friends,
like that phrase.
But anyway,
so,
and then when the 90s,
I did an op Ed piece for the New York
Times and I carefully left that part
out.
I just compared to use the frank dummy,
the mangoes drawing versus the Spanx.
But a couple of weeks later,
a letter was published from an order
from an orthodontist who also knows
about faces saying,
hey,
that swings is actually a sub Saharan
African face.
I didn't say it,
he sent it.
So I'm not in trouble for that.
But anyway until,
until something better is discovered.
It's a sub Saharan African face and we
don't know when it,
and it was really carved and,
and we don't know when it's entirely
possible that it used to be online.
And then some title,
the girl came along and said,
I don't like that line.
Well,
no,
it may have been that the head was so
weathered,
ah,
that over over time that they'd said,
well,
we can't,
we can't repair the face of the way that
we can repair the body.
And so they re carve the head.
And of course [inaudible] was most
likely still above ground while the rest
of the body was covered.
So it was a subject to more erosion.
Well,
it would not,
well,
it's also a harder limestones so
probably,
again,
this is speculation,
but we reckon that it,
an outcrop was done,
was sticking above the sand level to
begin with.
And somebody at some point,
the judge in years ago,
um,
decided to,
to,
to carve the swings by,
by cutting around it.
It's cutting the bedrock away from
around it,
leaving the outcrop above and carving
that into whatever it may have been
originally.
It could have been an African queen
would have been,
how much information did they lose when
the library of Alexandria was burned?
Well,
since it was burned,
we don't know.
All right.
It's amazing.
1 million scrolls which dragged that
they had a million scrolls.
Who knows what was on that.
One of my,
one of my,
one of my dreams have dreams but um,
sort of they didn't whatever.
But the hope is that one of these days
somebody turns over at spade and you
know,
when in Damascus or in somewhere up
there and discovers a cache of,
of you know,
of,
of hidden,
of hidden scrolls scrolls from the,
from the library of Alexandria.
It's quite probable that the so called
maps of the,
of the sea kings,
you know the peary reese map and some of
those other things are copies of maps
that were originally part of the part of
the library and I have a whole film
script actually.
What's the latest on this supposedly a
chamber that they found in the pause,
the Sphinx.
There's been some radio,
no us and that's awesome.
It's the seismograph says as the chamber
there and the seismograph doesn't
channel and it doesn't is united and the
geophysicist who did it said,
yeah,
there's a void down that I that mean
that it's,
it could be a natural void that's
certain kinds of limestone that riddled
with those kinds of voids,
but this isn't that kind of limestone.
So more more stuff.
When when the opposition finally caves
in and says they never say they're wrong
but and says,
well,
this deserves further study,
then maybe we get permission to go and
really look back in internet,
stick a probe down to something like
that and see if there is indeed
something in there.
We don't know.
God.
That seems like an important thing could
be.
I mean it just to find that there's
something there justifying there's
something there.
It's important.
Yes.
Now,
is there ever been any discussion
whatsoever about you?
I mean,
I know they've done all this,
a repair work on the Sphinx is ever,
ever been any discussion of taking the
limestone that was pulled from the Great
Pyramid and somehow or another putting
new limestone back up here to recreate
its original look?
No.
Nobody has ever talked about that as far
as I know.
But it would be a nightmarish job
because all of the,
all of those core blocks are all crumbly
and anamund and damage and stuff like
that.
And besides,
they have other fish to fry,
you know,
they've got the technology to worry
about.
I know,
but I mean just if people could see what
it used to look like,
you never did that when they redid it to
build Cairo acquired,
that's what they say.
I'm not even a hundred I've never seen
the study that actually has documented
where those stones are and they're big
massive stones and they slope like this.
You can't build a bridge out of those
stones,
you'd have to cut the edge off with is
almost as much work as querying this
stuff out of,
out of the room,
out of the,
out of the raw quarry rock,
which is closer to Cairo.
So what do you think happened?
I don't know.
I don't know,
but I'm,
I'm not 100% happy with that
explanation.
I don't have a better one
but,
but that one is subject to,
let's say a subject to question now.
Is it been firmly established that it
was covered in smooth limestone?
Pretty much,
yeah.
Pretty much.
Um,
yes.
Actually the,
the,
the Roman Greco Roman,
his writers who were there at the time
studying,
talked about it being absolutely perfect
and unpenetrable.
In fact,
one of them said there's a rumor that
there was a hinged block at the entrance
that have you pushed it at or you know,
did something with it.
It opened.
And I've often thought that,
I wonder if that's the origin of open
sesame and the in the thousand and one
nights,
because there are a lot of certain of
those thousand and one nights tales that
have their origins in ancient Egypt.
It would be a good study.
Go ahead.
Keep going.
What else we got here?
Oh that's the head of [inaudible] with
the,
with the Falcon while very different
face.
They totally different face.
I mean you can't miss that and there's
more long story,
but we were already going over here and
I won't go into here's this water
weathering that shot took one look at it
and said,
wow,
this looks like there are hundreds of
thousands of years old.
Just keep going now hundreds of
thousands of years.
I was is,
you know when the geologist,
he wasn't thinking what he was,
he was saying he was just saying it,
but it was massive water erosion.
It was massive water erosion by a guy
whose expertise is in,
is in that field.
So if he thought about it,
you know,
he can't document that until we get a
bunch of guys.
They're really looking seriously into
it.
But how old do you think it is if you
had know?
I don't know.
Um,
because of the way it's oriented.
One of the reasons they come out with
the date and handcock and above all
originally came out with his 11,500
because as a processional marker,
cause that's what would be the time as a
lion.
That would be the time when it last saw
its own image in the sky.
Leo The Lion,
the Constellation of Leo.
That would've been the last time I
think.
Not that there's too much that's going
on.
It's in too chaotic a stage two to have
been done.
Then I think it may be the press the age
before that,
which would be about 36,000
BC which would correspond to the
Egyptian texts themselves.
However,
that said,
it wouldn't surprise me if we her older
cell.
It's until we got a bunch of geologists
and experts in their various fields to
see if they can put a fix on it and they
might not be able to.
But that's what,
that's,
that's one of the things we look forward
to doing if we get permission to go back
in there and get the funding and you're
important and the permissions to go
there and actually get this done.
And this is where actually we were just
in Egypt.
I had when I climbed up and down the
pyramid myself at 84 and um,
we got complicated story,
but we did get to meet the new minister
of antiquities and it was very cordial
and,
and kind of listed the things that we
had to do in order to get formal
position,
but in any way we established a personal
contact with him,
which is very useful.
And then we also met up with the
director of this new gigantic museum
that they're building and that is going
to open in a year or two ago.
And he was,
he was very open to anything even
controversial that they could apply
science toe.
So if some of the other pieces of this
trip didn't go as planned,
we couldn't get the see some of the
things we wanted to see for complicated
reasons.
But anyway,
that we established the potential
foothold for getting the next stage of
the,
of work.
Very promising.
It's promising.
Now,
correct me if I'm wrong,
would they think that people in this
form the form of you and I have only
been around for somewhere around 300 to
500,000
years?
Is that right?
Well,
that's the current thing for trout and
it changes.
Yeah.
It changes.
It May.
So let's bring it back.
Let's go crazy and say it's a million
years old when,
when you're looking at something like
this and you're talking about 36,000
years,
boy,
that's,
uh,
it's just,
it's just crazy to think that there was
this period where people just throwing
shit at each other and you know,
and throwing a pointed sticks in animals
and,
and uh,
kind of barely getting by.
And then something like this just sort
of erupts out of the imagination and the
engine nuity of people that lived tens
of thousands of years ago.
Yeah.
But it shouldn't be that difficult
because as you keep going through the
slides,
you'll get to the Paleolithic caves and
I was out.
That's more evidence of water erosion,
correct?
No.
Can it right there?
No,
no.
I'm talking about,
know what I'm saying,
but bright there.
This image w right there,
I'll say me.
Which those little,
that's the same.
That's the same what?
What are weathering is just another view
of it.
Okay.
Back end of the Sphinx.
And that's interesting.
Anyway,
part of Mark Lane,
his theory is that,
you know,
is that it's,
it's,
it flaked away,
you know,
over time.
And that's what's responsible for these.
See the curved profile.
But this is a tomb that's been cut in.
It's old,
it's not old kingdom.
It's,
it's what's called late kingdom,
but it dates from about six or 700 BC.
And those are the Mason's marks still
adds original stuff.
20s,
2,600,
two and a half thousand years later.
Still perfectly visible.
No,
no theory theory exploded.
Well that definitely puts a damper on
the,
uh,
wind and sand erosion.
That too.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Especially considering that they still
think the spanx is 26 or 2,500
BC.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well,
this is,
remember I said the second strongest
thing in the world and this is not,
you don't trifle with them.
And then if you think that just because
the evidence is good enough,
they're going to accept it.
No,
they're only going to accept it when you
beat him into the ground sufficiently so
that they can't get up while as long as
the reputation is staked on their,
you know,
their original assumptions being
correct,
there's going to be a problem.
Oh,
and so there is,
yeah.
So what are we looking at here?
This is the corner of copper for up
here,
Ahmed.
And you'll see the two very different
styles of architecture,
the huge blocks below,
very finely dressed and the much cruder
core masonry up above this is evidence
of two separate stages of construction.
It's like if you had of your board of
Victorian House with an Ikea kitchen and
that you wouldn't say,
oh well they just decided to,
you know,
build this Victorian House and put this
cool new kitchen.
And now you'd know in two seconds that
it's two different stages of
construction.
Anyway,
we got a lot of tough stuff to cover
here.
Here.
What would stop you see where these
people are walking?
Do you see that?
This one block,
you see those people there and then all
the way down with the third guy down
there is walking.
There's another,
it goes down to there and then it goes
20 plus.
It's about 20 by 30 foot block and then
next to the next slide.
That's what it is,
ed,
John.
Those are the blocks people walking on
top.
That's what we would just looking at.
So those blocks are about between six
and eight feet thick.
Go back to the bottom line,
so not only they're six and eight feet
thick,
but they're stacked on top of each
other.
I'll try to build it up to that level.
Wow.
Six and eight feet thick and then
stacked on top of another one.
That's of a similar and I could go
poking back into it.
It's all,
you see the joints between the Merck
pretty rough,
but in fact if you poke back in there,
you'll see that they fit together,
that you can barely get a credit card
between them.
That's just,
that's,
you know,
lots and lots of weather over lots and
lots of years.
Then those are the,
the blocks of the great pyramid,
which a much smaller and almost pre,
almost presuppose a later state of
construction.
We had those same,
okay,
that's the Red Pyramid.
You know,
we're going to take up too much time
here.
Keep going.
Okay.
That's the interior of the Red Pyramid
and you see that's a megalithic
construction.
It's always called the plundered tomb
chamber.
A,
it's not a tomb chamber because nobody
was ever found in,
in it.
It doesn't look like any Egyptian tomb
chamber and B,
it's not plundered.
It's simply ruinous.
It's,
this is,
uh,
this is an earlier,
this is an earlier construction that for
whatever reason,
the builder of the red,
uh,
Red Pyramid decided to incorporate that
into his pyramid.
It's not like an Ikea kitchen
incorporated into the Victorian House.
It's something that was there before and
that they built the pyramid on top of.
So there's some older construction and
then in a better,
more stay up there.
Jamie,
stop moving a,
so what you're seeing the lower cruder
level is uh,
an older method of construction.
Then above it you see,
you look really smooth.
Yeah,
yeah.
My Macho well and also he has a really
smooth,
because it's in perfect shape.
There's nothing,
it's at the inside of the pyramid.
Nothing,
nothing could,
it's like it was done yesterday,
whereas the bottom has been out in the
weather for a long time.
That's the secret.
It's measured by,
it's weathered it not like the,
not like the exterior of the Sphinx,
but,
but it's style is typically is typically
a megalithic.
It looks like certain to the
constructions in,
in Ireland and Scotland and Wales and
Megalithic instructions there.
So you mean like a cruder cutting much,
much cruder but dating from an earlier
period,
six,
7,000
pcs.
So much like when they go and do
excavations in Mexico City,
they're always build.
They're building buildings down there
and they have to stop construction
because they find like some ancient
pyramid or something along those lines.
Exactly what this is is they had an old
structure and they built the new stuff
on top of it.
The new stuff is what we think of as the
original structure,
but there's evidence the point that
there was some ancient stuff below that.
Exactly.
Okay.
Interesting.
And what do we got here?
Well I that's more of shotgun myself.
Okay.
This is another piece of the puzzle.
This is part of Abi dose,
um,
behind the temple itself.
Temple this off to the right and this is
again,
a good friend of mine has just done an
elaborate book on this and even though
he's not an egyptologist,
it's being academically published,
but it's going into into all sorts of,
of things having to do with this strange
structure,
which is one of the most resonating
powerful places in all of Egypt.
We are convinced,
shocking myself that that was central
pillars date from a much earlier period.
And then the rest of the temple is Seti
the first,
which is about 1300 BC.
But this is to elaborate to get into
here and I'm running out of words.
Why do you think that it's older
one construction method,
style,
style of construction,
mostly style of construction and the way
that it's sided sort of buried into the
ground,
which is almost unheard of in it for an
Egyptian temple to be constructed into
as a subterranean structure would have
had a roof over it and so on at some
point or another.
But anyway,
that's it.
It's a complicated issue.
There it is.
It fills up with water sometimes and now
they won't let you end up.
But uh,
anyway,
this is with the,
this is us actually I the,
the Goonie oh.
And John Hancock and myself and handcock
and,
and the,
the Graham's still now he's getting a
bit cautious,
more cautious about it,
but we went finance
while this mega millionaire,
um,
Japanese,
industrialist,
um,
really,
I mean,
he wants it to prove the existence of
the Maria.
And as you see,
I mean all of those geometric,
um,
looks there.
And Chuck and I came to the conclusion
after a week of diving there,
that seductive as it looks,
it really is a natural,
entirely a natural way.
And we could even see,
we don't have the pictures of it because
it was the last day we there they could
even see the way that it was formed by
the,
the nature of the Rock and the action of
the waves and the terrific tides that,
that prevail there.
So this is what this,
that's me.
You can tell.
Um,
well you were so you actually did the
diving down there?
Yeah.
Oh,
when was that?
10,
12 years ago in my seventies.
What?
It's pretty gangster thing.
Yeah.
Well good
down the bottom of the ocean when you're
70 checking out rocks.
Well,
and I don't like being underwater
either,
but for archaeology I'll do it.
Okay.
Keep going.
Oh well this is the famous,
this is the famous cartoon that some
people think or his hair.
These are now,
these are the Paleolithic caves.
This is the best of them called
[inaudible].
This is day two,
this is in France or this is in France
and this day date,
they date,
not us.
They date to 31,000
BC or older.
This is genius stuff.
Um,
great artists did this.
Great artists are not primitive then you
might be shooting arrows at rhinoceroses
to eat and why not?
It's a lot better than going to the
supermarket and the organic or you have
ever,
you never heard of a gmo rhinoceros but,
but this is,
this is fabulous work and who knows what
was going on the rest of the time when
they're doing this in the dark,
hidden away in these caves.
And this is 31,000
BC.
So the date where us of 36,000
or thereabouts for,
you know,
for the spanx and all of that is not as
out of out of the question as,
as you think,
because they date this the 31,000.
And this presupposes a,
uh,
an extremely sophisticated art artistry
and supremely sophisticated art.
History is not done by morons or by,
by primitives.
It just isn't.
Keep going.
Look at this great stuff.
Yeah,
they definitely had a very good sense of
how to capture what these animals that
they worshiped and went after looked
like.
But it was a crazy,
here you see that looks like a rhino
down there and horses.
It is.
And the horses,
wild horses mile or maybe go back.
We tapped the artists artists study of
go back to time.
Correct me if I'm wrong,
but I think they've only uncovered less
than 10% of go back.
We test much less,
I think it's 5% or something like that.
And they work well now it's near the
Syrian border.
So God knows what they're doing,
but they're covering it over because
once they started excavating it,
I've been protected by the fill role of
these thousands of years and it started
deteriorating.
So now they've unfortunately you can no
longer see it the way the chalk and I
saw it six,
seven years ago.
So what are they covering it with?
Oh,
they've got sheds and roofs.
Silver.
It completely destroyed.
It's magic,
but I can't blame them.
The weather is getting at it.
Well,
they've only,
when did they discover this?
It was actually discovered in the 1994
or so and they've been working on it
ever since and it only came into public
view around 2004 or there abouts.
And here,
here's some of the detail and which is
why shock is fascinated by this because
that kind of thing of the
anthropomorphic of the,
of the hands grasping around the corner
that's doing that was something almost
identical to that.
And Easter Island,
we think Easter island plays a role in
this whole lost civilization hypothesis.
Wow,
that's more,
again,
this has raised relief.
You have to chop the soane cut or a
braid,
the stone away from the figures.
This is tough to do.
It's three d stuff.
And also aren't there to animals
depicted on these things that aren't
even local.
They're not even available in that
continent and on nor did they think
there's a history of these animals.
I am not sure this is what this one is,
the,
that one.
There is a kind of a feline of some
sorts,
um,
hard to tell exactly what it is cause
it's stylized with it.
It's a pretty brilliant piece of
sculpture and you have to,
you know,
carve away the holds stone surface in
order to get at that with,
I'm not sure if they,
if they know or some eyes what that is.
Yeah,
I definitely would start some sort of
like half cuma,
some sort of a,
some sort of a humorous,
this is interesting.
That's a bead that they found there from
go back to the topic and the,
this is a big mystery in a small bead.
It was,
how did they drill that hole?
It's a very,
very,
very hard stone.
Very hard stone.
A very small stone to sitting in your
hand that's about the size of yours.
You're the last digit of your thumb.
It's tiny.
It's tiny and it's thin.
And so there's a tiny little hole in
that.
And again,
we're talking about a time where there
was no steel.
That's right.
So how did they do that?
Exactly?
There's a bunch of pottery in Egypt in
terms of a carved stone where they have
zero idea how they,
how they constructed it with a very thin
lip and then it goes inside contour.
Yeah,
I think we have one of those there.
This is a,
this is a bracelet found recently in
Turkey,
had made of Obsidian,
which is an almost impossible stone to
work with and the ridges on it.
They,
again,
not us have found by doing a careful
study of it geometrically,
that it's very sophisticated geometry at
work.
I forget exactly what it is that set at
issue here,
but it's not just a cup of cavemen
saying like,
you know,
my wife is pissed off at me,
so I better give her something nice for
our anniversary.
Clark said,
well,
here's a nice chunk of obsidian.
I think I'll,
I'll,
uh,
I'll do a little bracelet for her and
don't know how all this is.
The data is by the Strada that it's
found in around 8,000
BC.
Wow.
Okay.
This is more stuff.
This is Sardinia,
which is a treasure of Megalithic UN
misunderstood.
Look at these extreme plastic
structures.
We think shotgun myself that this may be
a lot of,
this may be an answer to this massive
coronal mass ejection that happened
maybe thousands of years earlier.
Even in people are still building things
to keep them safe from another one of
these.
Now what would be the effect of a
coronal mass ejection right now but
catastrophe,
right as far as it'd be now it would,
it would kill the satellites and it
would freeze the we'd read it would fry
the grid.
I mean instantly the only people who
would hang the only people who would
survive or the survivalist who are off
the grid that because we're all assholes
with those kinds of survivalist.
No problem.
Yeah that was those kinds of cars but
other people are off the grid,
you know doing um,
my pal clay who's here buying tena extra
acres that I have,
I'm not doing anything with and is
planning to in fact do exactly that to
go off the grid and build a permaculture
10 acre self sustaining self sustaining
is a great way to do it.
To have like a farm and if you can
afford the land and have solar power and
all that counseling well water,
a few people are doing that.
It's possible.
There are some people,
but you know when,
when the world is overpopulated to the
extent that it is,
it's not going to get to an awful lot of
people very quickly.
It's,
it's difficult to do.
Yeah.
These are the interior of those
extraordinary neurology they called.
So identity is incredible place
actually.
And that's an Italy right island off the
coast of,
wow,
what do they date?
These two will Bei data to 2,600
or so,
2,600
BC.
And Chuck and I questioned that,
but we don't have,
we don't have any data that that tells
us otherwise was that is the stone
circle in Egypt and knobbed apply as
it's called,
that it looks completely fragmented and
rough,
but in fact even this,
the academics,
the Rko astronomers acknowledge
architect is astronomically and there's
a physicist archioffice Toronto named
Tom Brophy who studied it much more
carefully and has found much more
sophisticated alignments than just
salts.
This is an equinox is again,
cause that's a,
that's a common thread in ancient,
uh,
architecture,
which is really fascinating,
is the,
the alignment with a celestial bodies.
Mayans always big on that little way as
well.
What they're doing back to procession
for whatever reason that we don't
understand.
But with the evidence is there,
there and the festivals and all sorts of
things like that are attuned take place
at these,
at these critical,
these critical,
let's call them energy points and what
they're doing,
and it's quite clear that they're doing
it,
is that they're,
they're orchestrating their attire,
civilization that tuning their entire
civilization to the movements of the
heavens.
This is quite clear and this you can
kind of demonstrate what they're
achieving by that.
We don't know,
but it's very important to them.
What are we go here?
More,
more of the same.
That's the Devil's Dick.
Well,
close.
It looks so good.
Yeah.
That's the,
that's not apply.
And that just the drawing and not apply
on this is this gets into complications
of the cosmology of it.
This is the dog and this is the work of
my good friend,
a layered scranton who you may know of,
I think.
Yes,
yes.
And the Dogon tribe,
that's a tribe to think that they're,
they come from the constellation
serious.
Well where,
who think they got their knowledge
yesterday?
It comes to it through them directly
from serious,
I don't think they think they come from
serious,
I'm not sure.
But anyway,
layered work started out just as a sort
of amateur thing.
I'm looking for looking into the
cosmology of the Dogan and at a certain
point he decides to see how that matches
current cock in technology.
He's a techie guy,
he's a expert in computer languages and
things like that.
So He's,
he's,
he's very good at this kind of work.
And he finds that in the first book of
his called science at the Dogan,
um,
that this Dogan cosmology of this,
you know,
read the Sim simple tribe in,
um,
western western Africa,
Mali,
I think it is.
Um,
has their cosmology,
which is,
they know about,
they can transmit it is in fact
consistent with the latest wrinkles and
string theory in torsion theory in high
energy physics and all that sort of
stuff.
And then that led him to the study of
other civilizations and he's now,
it was six or seven books into it.
And really what he's doing as he's not
just talk,
it's unrecognized by a handful of
people.
You know,
they're hot by sellers and the written
very well.
It's very,
very simple and easy to find,
easy to follow.
He's,
he's showing that this,
this complex cosmology is understood
unexpressed by every society,
virtually every society that he's looked
into,
including the Chinese.
Um,
that was a relatively recent book and
he's ending up by with a master,
a picture puzzle of all of these ancient
civilizations.
No dating them.
Exactly.
But it's become quite clear through this
body of work that the ancients had this
same,
the fact that Lee,
the same cosmology and the same
understanding of it.
And we think that this is a hand me down
from the ancient civilization that we're
busy trying to,
to validate and the
[inaudible] the survivors of this
coronal mass,
this,
the survivors of the curve,
the pdf that existed before the coronal
mass that achieve some sort of a high
level of sophistication.
And then these people with whatever
knowledge was leftover,
whatever,
they had managed to save something of
that sort or they with the same people
who are everywhere and had it to begin
with.
What you're seeing up here,
figure 12.4
the quantum fresno frenzy can cause a
string anti string pair to erupt and
annihilate yielding and more complicated
interaction.
What does that,
well,
that's from,
again,
that's from the physics lab actually.
Are they talking about,
I'm not sure if it's like some sort of a
geometry thing and,
or the physics thing and they're looking
at this is Dogan art,
is that what this is?
No,
but Dogan has has that figure in it.
Keep going down
down.
I think.
Let's say there's some way the Dogan
have that there.
It's,
where is it,
Jamie?
Okay.
No,
nope.
Hmm.
I think it's the one right after.
It says very close.
Let's see.
Anyway,
and it once you have to read Larry's
book,
science of the dog,
and that's really all there.
And then it's the same in all of the
civilizations all over the place.
And as I said earlier,
I don't,
I dislike,
okay.
Using the Old Testament,
the Bible for,
for scholarship because it's a minefield
you just don't know.
You can select from it.
I mean,
you know,
the inquisitor's found a way to justify
the inquisition from the Bible and you
can justify just about anything with so
much craziness in the,
so much,
so much craziness going on in there.
But one thing that did strike me and the
correspondence is our correspondence is
one of the,
one of the intriguing bits of,
of the,
um,
of,
I forget where it is,
tower of Babel of it's exodus or no,
can't be activist.
Genesis
may be.
Anyway,
one of the early books of the Bible
where they talk about the tower of Babel
and one of the lines,
it's very suggestive,
is this before the or before the,
the tower was built,
all of all of humanity spoken one
tongue.
The eskimos spoke the same as the
Polynesians.
What is this,
you know,
in the Polynesians spoke Chinese.
Now it doesn't seem,
it doesn't seem logical.
I mean the linguists don't find that
sort of thing.
But if the common language that they
spoke was the cosmology and laird finds
the same cosmology wherever he looks.
That's interesting.
That's not anything that you can base,
you know,
you can't be sure of it,
but suddenly that that's strange line
does have some corroboration.
I think it's very hard for us to put
into perspective what it would be like
if there was some sort of a high level
of sophistication involved in the
society back then and then the
experienced whatever it was,
whether it was meteor showers,
supervolcanoes what that asteroid has
dried.
Yeah,
and whatever it is and then trying to
retain a certain amount of it and pass
it onto your children and how things
would get so convoluted and distorted
and there'd be very little left.
Yes.
Yeah.
I mean like then it's an,
but the people would be of the same
sophistication in terms of the same kind
of minds,
the same sized brains,
the same capability.
They would just have to relearn
anything.
Hang all over again.
Well let's this.
This is a good,
I think there's a good case that can be
made for that because stuff gets after
we're after this cat catastrophe.
Things really do go into a tailspin and
then around 3000 BC,
4,000
BC,
all of a sudden all over the place,
very sophisticated civilizations arise,
but based upon this,
this ancient knowledge though the,
the mythology is all there to begin
with,
but suddenly the Sumerian around the
same time,
this Egypt,
there's,
there's China for sure.
There's India and all of these,
all of these seem to arrive at a very
high level of understanding around that
4,000
or so he date,
especially Samir,
when they go over some of the ancient,
those saw clay tablets.
When they see the depictions of the
solar system,
that's where it gets really confusing.
It's like,
how the hell did they know this?
How do they know that there was a sun in
the center and then all these planets
were in the correct size?
I mean,
they had jupiter and the correct size
and the correct position.
Mars in the correct position was very,
very strange stuff.
I didn't know that.
I ever seen.
Beautiful.
But if you are followed Zacharias hitch
and stuff was he's got some really wacky
shit.
Well it is wacky.
Peter Fonda read if you're hot.
Yeah,
but it's a the Annunaki and those from
heaven to Earth came and people out of
monkeys and alien DNA is a galactic
Darwinian while he was,
now he's how he's always wearing food
and I call his,
I call him,
I called his father was switching in
these,
well,
uh,
I read the use for the 12th planet to
think that was called the 12th planet.
Horrible stuff yet.
But when you know,
when you don't know anything it's
awesome.
But I pull up the image Jamie of the,
just to show it to 'em John of the solar
system depiction in the clay tablets
because it's really fascinating stuff.
I mean it clearly shows a son with what
we,
you know,
the,
our standard sort of image of a sun.
It's a circle and the radiating sort of
lines outside of it.
And then it has all these planets
circling around it.
Yeah,
there it is right there.
Look at that.
Oh,
the sun is a star.
No,
that's just,
it's not a drawing.
It's just outlined.
That's the actual original clay tablet.
But they drew on as an outline,
but he's not amazing.
I mean you could find the actual tablet
Jamie too,
cause he and he can zoom in on it so you
could see it better,
but really,
really incredible stuff when you
consider the fact that they,
uh,
made this somewhere around,
what was his 5,000
BC?
4,000
I don't know.
I think it was that one right there
was that early,
but it's somewhere,
somewhere in that neighborhood.
See if you can find a better full
version of it.
Yeah.
They're young Jimmy,
but
incredible stuff and weird stuff.
And I mean there are depictions of
people with tails sitting on the labs of
giants and
that,
that tends to decode symbolically
actually those hybrid creature type
stuff like that.
Yeah.
Those,
those,
most of those things I think should not
be taken literally.
Right.
Um,
like you were talking about myths.
Yeah.
The myths because things change shape
and the one thing becomes another.
And when does a shung pictorially it,
it doesn't mean that it's to be taken.
Literally there's the original,
so you could see it there in the
background.
Pretty interesting stuff,
Huh?
But where,
where are they in the background?
Where,
see right there.
Oh yeah.
And
but the stars,
that's the original.
You have the sun and the moon.
The stars actually that's a motif that
you see in Egypt often.
Really where you have,
where you have a star with the solar
disk and in,
in,
in the middle of it.
And often they're just stars.
That five points that stars and then
it's with the solar disk in it and what
they're talking about.
I think the egyptologists talk about a
stellar cult and the solar cult and that
as soon as you call anything to cult,
it becomes,
you can talk about it because it's
somebody else's religion,
therefore a superstition.
But what,
what,
what it's talking about.
And probably this too,
um,
it's,
it's two levels.
In other words,
it's the,
it's the solar sky,
our solar system and the star around it
is,
there's a diagonal sky is the
constellation Constellation in the sky.
So it's two,
two levels of the hierarchy
simultaneously.
But it,
yeah,
just amazing that you're talking about
such a long,
long time ago.
And they had all the little planets
there,
but all the,
well they have,
they don't have your innocent,
they don't have urinary,
see what they have there.
Do they pull it back up again?
Jamie?
I'm finding a couple of different
versions.
So there's more than one version of it.
Yeah.
One only had seven planets.
They have another one that was nine.
It was shit.
Ah,
that's interesting.
If they have,
medicine only has seven.
That was a different one where that
shows a star and then it has a bunch of
plants off to the side.
Who knows what that means.
Go full you on that one,
Jamie.
Yeah,
look at that one.
It's just so cool to look at something
that someone made,
you know,
whatever,
five thousand six thousand years ago and
see there
dare attempt.
Go back to that police there,
tamped at trying to,
uh,
show and convey what they knew about the
world or what their thoughts were about
the world.
Like what are we seeing
here?
It looks like war.
That one is not well,
that's a common theme.
And,
and uh,
that's a common theme in Egypt to the
Pharaoh,
the Pharaoh smiling,
smiling in the heads of the,
of his enemies.
It's the conquest of the forces of light
over the forces of darkness.
And this one,
the seven might not be there.
It is,
um,
have that you have that,
as I said off often in Egypt or are very
similar,
but the other one,
the star and the seven,
the seven planet,
it could be planets,
but see it's a different looking star to
it's many one too.
That's a different one.
The other one,
six,
it might be,
it might be a number symbolism thing
with the thing and the,
and the numbers.
Egyptians do seven not as circles like
that,
but as,
as as dots.
It's,
you know,
it has,
it has a numerical validity rather than
necessarily than an astronomical one.
That one,
the other one and go back the other one,
Jim.
Yeah,
no,
that,
that one's,
that one's really interesting.
Yeah.
All this stuff is an interest.
The relative sizes,
the relative sizes,
that's pretty mind boggling.
Yeah.
And again,
the two,
the two on the,
on the outer edge is really those two.
Yeah,
that's,
that's interesting.
Yeah.
Very interesting indeed.
I'd like to see that explained any other
way than,
than uh,
they knew something.
I mean,
or it's an amazing lucky.
Yes.
No,
this is not guesswork.
it's just a unraveling ancient
civilization.
It's like putting together a puzzle when
you only have five,
six pieces.
Well,
we're,
this is the thing that when we started
out there were a few pieces and then now
a lot of pieces have been added to the
puzzle.
Right.
But the nuclear glass,
the coronal mass ejection go back to
[inaudible] is a big chunk of Gunung
Padang.
And in,
uh,
Indonesia is another one that I don't
have any photos.
Event with chalk has been to that and is
absolutely convinced that at very,
very low aa that it's,
that it's human made and that it's very,
very old.
These things are showing up all over the
place.
So go back to this slides and,
um,
it's just,
it's such an emerging thing as far as
like,
uh,
people talking about it to the slides.
Um,
this is something that's being discussed
over and over again.
Now it's much more mainstream.
And now that Graham Hancock has got a
lot of traction on his work and his new
book,
magicians of the Gods and Randall
Carlson,
who's an expert on asteroidal impacts,
has sort of impacted his work as well
and really,
Eh,
uh,
sort of,
um,
made it more interesting because he's
provided a context with some historical,
uh,
like actual scientific evidence of
impacts.
No.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Go along with it.
So what are we looking at here?
That's,
that's called Beckley tip.
Hey,
again,
I'm,
but I'm not,
yeah,
that's all right.
Might go back to these heavy,
that's not the Playa,
but that's one of shocks when a shuck
slides I think,
and I'm not sure what he's,
what he's driving at there in the
background.
That's Brophy's I think that's brophy's
slides of where he's looking for much
more sophisticated information in the,
in,
in the Playa.
And even if he's,
even if it's more far out speculations,
I just speculation.
I think they could be just the basic,
the basic premise is already,
um,
of great significance that,
that,
that this is cause this is dated to
five,
6,000
BC.
So that makes it the oldest datable
stone circle.
Now,
one of the things I was going to bring
up with you,
I forgot when we were talking earlier
about this,
uh,
idea of the procession of equinox is,
the wobble of the earth being caused
perhaps by a dwarf star that we don't
know exactly where it is.
Uh,
that was one of the theories about
whatever it is outside of the Kuyper
belt that,
uh,
there's this object out there now that
they're 90% plus sure exists and they're
calling it,
you know,
planted acts or whatever it is.
They think that it's at least four times
larger than the earth and it's some
somewhere outside of the Kuyper belt,
which is now what they believe Pluto is
a part of.
Right.
Pluto when it,
okay,
when Pluto is no longer a planet,
it got listed as an asteroidal.
Pluto downgraded got the shaft,
but they think there's something out
there.
And one of us,
one of the theories that I had read was
that it could be some sort of a dwarf
star that is a,
that exists so far out there that we
can't see it.
Oh,
well the brown door,
I mean,
walter cutting didn't,
who runs,
who started sea pack would be,
I don't know.
He knows about that.
I'll be seeing him in a few days and
some interesting stuff going on at seed
packets.
It's strange.
You didn't know about it.
Well you know about the planet that they
were pretty sure of.
Right.
Do you know about that?
I think,
well,
let's see if he could find that.
Like they,
they think that somewhere outside of
Pluto that there is a large body,
they don't know what it is.
They don't know exactly how big it is,
but they think it's far larger than the
earth.
Uh,
at least four times larger than the
earth.
And that it exists and it's,
it's gravitational effect is having a
response here.
It is new dwarf planet discovered far
beyond Pluto's or no,
Jamie.
That's not it at all.
I think that's a different,
that's a dwarf planet.
This is something that's much larger.
This is like a,
they think it's larger than earth.
Lou just look up planet four times
larger than Earth believe to be outside
of the solar system.
They think it's a part of the solar
system,
but it's on this gigantic orgo like way,
way,
way out there.
So most of them are binary star systems,
right?
Most of them.
I think so.
Yeah.
Shock would know that.
He knows.
Is astronomy a lot better than I do.
But it's interesting if there is some
sort of a star or a dead star out there
way out there.
Yeah.
And then it's affecting us.
It's causing our earth to wobble.
Maybe.
Yeah.
I mean here it is as Toronto merce say a
nap.
No,
no,
not,
nope.
Do Nothing.
Does that.
It looks bad.
Is that it?
Well,
Neptune's big.
It could be.
It might be hit January 20th yeah.
Okay.
That's right.
Yeah.
I didn't see that one.
The claim is the strongest yet in a
century's long search for planet x
beyond Neptune nuquest has been plagued
by far fetched claims and even outright
quackery.
But the new evidence comes from a pair
of respected planetary scientists.
I want to say that guy,
the language,
look at the language yet it's quackery.
If they don't agree,
and if it's not one of their own,
and if it's one of their own,
it's respected until somebody comes
along and shows that they're wrong.
Right.
But their language is tempered by guys
like Zacharias H isn't it?
Well,
yeah,
he brings it on himself.
That's right.
Right.
But some of that stuff,
it's,
it's equal.
That's why I call them the core
academics because every week there's
something coming along this proving
stuff that they'd been insisting has
been right for the last 10 or 15 or 20
years.
Look at this thing.
But they're never quacks.
They think it orbits the sun every
15,000
years.
Right.
Yeah.
Okay.
Wow.
That's awesome.
I mean it's just,
it's so interesting.
We know so much,
but so little at the same time.
You know,
uh,
I think it was Dennis.
Yeah.
Dennis Mckenna had this great saying
that when the bonfire of,
uh,
I was a,
how they work,
a bonfire of understanding grows,
it illuminates the surface area of
ignorance.
Well,
good line.
Yeah.
That you realize like the brighter the
light,
like,
wow,
there's so much you don't know.
And then all the,
you have to distinguish between
knowledge and understanding.
The example with the crack epidemic
egyptologists they,
they have a lot of facts that it's this
well so that they do not understand at
all.
And that's why,
I mean my own work schwaller is on work,
couldn't have been done without all of
that careful factual work.
Let the Egyptologist and what I do,
who would we do?
I mean those of us who are looking into
this,
we take that factual material and
Schwaller rise it and that gives us a
certain degree of understanding those
Derek stone to have it all those jerks.
Let's go back to the slides.
What else you got here that you want to
show us?
I don't know.
This is a lot but some stuff I want to
skip.
Okay,
keep going.
I wanted to skip stuff now cause I'm
getting,
I'm running out of words,
which is hard to do.
These are the,
that's one of those very hard stone
vase,
um,
with this thin lip and the walls of the
vas are about as thick as the rim of the
lip.
And this is all made out of one,
one,
uh,
piece of a very hard stone cold green
shifts.
And we think actually shocking myself
and as an idea,
if I had another friend of mine,
good,
very good writer named Paul William
Roberts was his suggestion that hey,
maybe these stone thinks it's,
it'll quite a few of them date from the
earlier period and had were kept as
sacred objects all of those years.
And of course if they were kept in
guarded and not broken and a hammer,
brexit but were kept in touch in in one
piece,
you know,
x number of thousand years that wouldn't
be weathered or anything,
they'd be fine as long as they were
protected.
Now is there any speculation whatsoever
as to the method that they use to create
something like this?
Some stupid ones.
Let's hear the stupid ones so that
they're shown with bow drills that you
know that the way like you light a fire
with sticks like this.
Well it's a kind of a drill that they
put in there with bulls of some kind of,
you know,
hard stone and once you get the drill
thing down you can kind of work your way
around and gradually,
gradually,
gradually hollow out the inside.
This seems insane to me and that it
would take,
I mean,
one of those guys should devote his life
to taking a block of green schist and
trying that method and see how far he
gets in 10 or 15 years.
It's very hard to imagine that they
could do that with a method like that,
but it's otherwise no one knows.
But isn't that like sort of a,
it doesn't balance out with the insanity
of building a pyramid in the first
place.
Okay.
I mean,
building a pyramid,
it's just incredible undertaking.
Then they say that like if you cut in
place 10 songs a day,
it would take you 664 years.
It is mind boggling.
Yeah.
But,
but,
uh,
in fact,
um,
it's quite clear that they did it.
It's,
it's not at all clear that they did it
in the allotted 25 years as something
that's sort of why they did it.
I mean,
again,
does he do it to an academic?
The only possible explanation is that
they were tombs,
even though there's no evidence
whatsoever that they were tombs.
But if they say they were tombs,
they don't need that.
What do you think they were?
I don't know except what I'm pretty sure
is that they weren't tombs in the,
and they weren't tunes only.
My,
my gentle sense of it is that since
everything and Egypt has as its focus,
the quest for immortality in some way,
shape or form,
they enhance that quest.
They make it possible to do things that
you wouldn't otherwise do.
I can tell you,
you've got enough people together and
come on a trip,
I'll come on your own and we do our two
hour meditation in the pyramid.
You come out of there and knowing that
you not been just in a quiet bathroom,
um,
it,
this place surges with power.
You've got a group of people in there,
all of whom are,
especially if are some whoever the
practice of meditation,
it's,
it's really,
it's something and I mean you come out
of there knowing that you've experienced
something that you've not experienced
before.
So how they were used and to what end,
I don't know.
I mean this is a quite common theory
that there were sites of high
initiation.
Well there are sites of high initiation
and when you understand what initiation
involves,
that's not a,
that's not a dumb theory.
It is a dumb theory.
If you don't think there's such a thing
as initiation and if you think that
illumination is dependent upon
electricity,
well you're not be able to think of
Egyptian.
But if,
if you've been to the Po to the places
and have experienced it yourself,
the power of these places then exploit
explanations of that sort even though
they don't count as
speculative for sure.
But when you don't have any evidence for
them being tombs,
that's pretty speculative to right.
And building them is incredible.
Beyond belief.
Lighting them up is only slightly less
incredible.
Yeah,
it's the whole thing.
Do you have any theories at all is how
they could build some sort of a stone?
No,
no.
I don't.
Pretty incredible stuff.
But let's go up cause we got a lot of
stuff and I don't want to take her.
Okay.
That's us.
My criminal partner,
Boris swinging the digital sledge hammer
looking for underground caverns.
So what did you hit that thing and it
makes us sound and this sound
seismograph two goes into the earth.
Interesting.
The next slide is what we found and
there it has the Aa that's,
that's the,
that is a cavern or a chamber or of some
sort.
It's a void underneath the bedrock and
that's the so called hall of records.
People think that that's Edgar Casey is
talking about.
We're iffy about it.
Other than that,
the seismograph does not know how to
channel.
So it just says what's there and it
knows there's a void and at the very
back it's a little bit,
you don't see,
it's the edge of the CC at the very end
by the rump that is also a chamber and
that's absolutely,
it's known that it's there and this
gives you the same profile sizemore
logically,
but there's no seismograph Bentley's
things.
Yeah,
the back one,
there's a way,
it's a very rough cut chamber and
there's a just behind them,
one of those stones because if you pull
it away and you can get in and it's a
room rough,
it's very rough.
But about the size of the room that
we're in here at the studio and that's a
room.
So if that's a room,
then it stands to reason that seismic
graphical reason anyway,
that a is also a,
a cavern or a grotto or construction or
something.
So what we're looking at with a,
when you see all those circles around it
and the,
the rough shape of it,
that's the shape that they believe the
room is.
So it'd be similar to the one that's at
the ramp where it would be like kind of
a rod meld.
Well,
the,
the seismic graphic,
those are the,
I forget the top of the lines of
something that gives you the depths of,
the thing is that,
and but it's not like a square 90 degree
angle.
It's roughly rectangular.
Says Tom,
Tom Dubecky,
who is our Geo Geo physicist who was
doing that work.
So what's the hold up as far as
examining that?
Well,
two one,
they don't want to be wrong to that.
It's very difficult to do.
It's under about five.
The about 15 feet of bedrock that
haven't,
the Sphinx is a,
probably the the most,
let's say that the archeological hot
spot of the universe.
I mean nothing is more open to,
you know,
excitement and all the rest of it is the
swinks.
Secondly,
the water level has risen so that that
whole chamber is probably filled with
water now.
So anything that isn't stone would have
been obliterated long ago when I was at,
he got down there and you're found with
wet scrolls,
well maybe or or stone something or in
that,
but in theory you could put a little
fiber optic something down there and
study it,
but they don't want to be wrong about
this and anything invasive.
The Sphinx is really in disastrous
conditions.
So any little vibration or something
like that could,
you know,
could could conceivably damage it.
I don't worry about these things.
The geology is much more important as
far as I'm concerned.
And my guess is that when we finally
break open the port colors and capture
all of the,
you know,
all of the capture,
all of the,
the,
the core academics that,
that it protects it,
the moment,
um,
which I dunno,
maybe we'll waterboard them,
but anyway,
we can,
we capture all of the academics and get
them the hell out of there at that point
when it gets,
when it is,
when it is accepted and these things do
happen.
This is idea whose time has come,
when it has come,
things change.
And at that point maybe then the funding
shows up and the,
and the,
and the determination comes up to
actually look into that void or chamber
and see if it is indeed avoid or chamber
and if there's something in there,
is it possible that there's some other
things in Egypt that haven't been
discovered yet?
Load,
even though where they are a lot of them
because,
yeah,
but what do you call it?
Landsat,
uh,
infrared.
Something,
you know when you can photograph
underground?
They have,
yeah,
they,
there are hundreds of sites that they
know where their graves and tombs and
stuff like that,
but most of them,
I don't think the,
I don't think that kind of photography,
I thought there's a name for it.
I don't think that kind of photography
goes deep enough from for us to
establish the,
the lost civilization.
It will be under the sand level.
It'll be at the bottom of the sand level
and so far at any rate it doesn't get
down that deeply,
but they have lots of places to excavate
of that.
The money.
Let's keep going here.
Keep going.
Okay.
Well this is now,
this is chuck's book and he'll be at
Seapak.
This is a recent book.
That's his last book.
Yeah.
That's a recent book.
The role of solar outbursts in our past
and future for gotten civilizations of
title.
Yeah,
very,
very interesting.
Very interesting thesis and backed up by
a lot by,
you know,
a lot of solid,
a lot of solid scholarship and chocolate
would be at the seat pack.
This particular seat back,
so he thinks it was a,
uh,
a sore outburst more than they think it
was an asteroidal impact.
He thinks,
although they're not necessarily
antithetical the dates,
the dates,
in other words,
it could have been either.
I mean,
shock shock thinks that it's a,
an impact in the earlier catastrophe
that brings on the younger dryas that,
that the,
the intensification of the Ice Age and
he thinks that it's the solar outburst
that that puts an end to the entire
civilization and melts all the ice.
Whoa.
Wow.
A northern lights.
What else we got?
Well,
I'd keep going.
Does this go whisk by here because this
is Anthony [inaudible] who was a
physicist at the,
it's his thing.
Then here,
these are these figures that show up in
the,
you know,
in,
in the electro,
through the electron microscope and that
are mirrored by those strange dancing
multi-headed multi-armed figures at the
petroglyphs at the top.
Usually at the upper registers of those,
of the petroglyph facade facade,
which also mirrors,
that's the wrong go wrong.
Go scripture.
Aftershock is fascinated by the so far
untranslatable Rango rango script.
We're aside from Easter island,
which shows as as letters,
presumably those kinds of weird humanoid
figures.
One of the great mysteries of linguists.
Oh Yeah Huh?
Chro.
Qigong as at the bottom of the whole
thing of my whole show.
Yup.
Really with a whole bunch of other stuff
that I wanted on it.
Not,
well,
some stuff I didn't want I wanted to
whisk through,
but what was up there that maybe I'll
send it to you is the map of them fuck
stan of greater and Lesser Dumbfuckistan
which is,
which is very useful and my five cowboys
and then the graphic of the five cowboys
jury graphic.
My stepson found it somewhere online,
but it really shows the fun.
It's cowboys and action,
which is,
as I said,
you pick up the pickup,
the daily newspaper or turn on the
Internet and just see the cowboys at
work.
You've been at this for a long time now.
Yeah,
late sixties [inaudible] I was born,
yeah.
I was born in 67 well that's a around
that's around the time I came across.
Schwaller deliberate,
yes.
Around them.
Do you feel like people are slowly but
surely starting to come around at these,
the,
the concepts of these ancient
civilizations being not the primitive
people that we've been told,
but maybe perhaps just really complex?
Oh yeah.
Well a lot of people,
the trouble is that it's,
that the,
the,
the picture is muddied.
I mean the academics there as almost as
academics errors staunches ever in
their,
in their delusion.
But the trouble is that the whole
scenario is,
is muddied and it's almost unavoidable
by ancient aliens in Zechariah said Chin
and a whole bunch of nutcases that think
that aliens built the pyramids and all
of that sort of stuff.
So yes,
more people are interested,
but how many,
the percentage of those that are
actually capable of,
of sifting the evidence and
intellectually honest enough to accept
what stands up to scrutiny and not
numerically there,
there are lots more of them than they
were,
but
there are very,
very small percentage of very,
very small percentage of the populace
that actually care or understand it.
But it only takes a certain small
percentage of you ever tried to get
your,
your magical Egypt series on Netflix?
No,
not,
not on Netflix,
but they probably wouldn't take it
because they'd have to,
they'd have to make a cup to cut a
really lousy deal with them and be,
um,
the,
the numbers probably wouldn't justify
it.
I don't know about that.
Well,
they did love documentaries.
And why would you think that,
uh,
they would want to cut a lousy deal?
They do.
I mean,
they,
they really,
they really don't give you much.
I mean,
the mystery of the swings is on there,
but it's the guy who,
I'm the guy who,
uh,
who did the,
who does the reproduction of it,
that,
that negotiated with them and chance the
downside of chances that he's a bit
paranoid about letting stuff out of his
control.
So I've told him,
you know,
cause that's the thing on Netflix or I
mean people have stolen it and it's on
youtube in a very,
you know,
in a very,
it's at the reproduction you really
don't see it unless you actually own the
DVD and,
but it's chances baby as far as,
as,
as pitching it and he doesn't,
then it's not,
so he hasn't even brought it up to
Netflix.
I don't know if he has or not.
It seems like it'd be right up their
alley you would think.
But I,
I've given up that of arguing the case
of he doesn't,
it says it's his,
it's his baby is,
it's not,
I mean it is and it's not,
but it's a big part of your work.
I mean,
I just think that that would be a great
venue for it.
I think it would be too,
but you write him and tell him that I
have a netflix trying to get on your
show for a while and hasn't been,
well,
he's been emailing you a couple of
times.
Nobody me on the wrong address and
nobody responded.
So he gives up anyway.
I never got any emails from the dude.
Well,
I'll talk about that after the show.
We'll try to figure that out.
But,
uh,
I got a comedy special coming out on
Netflix and October.
Yeah.
Be Happy to talk to them and say,
Hey,
this is something I should look at.
I don't have any idea what kind of deals
they cut in terms of documentaries,
but what I do know is that what you did
is amazing.
And then I think that it would,
uh,
it would,
it would be great for everybody to have
that have more access by just the,
just the sheer depth of the information
when you go over like the temple and man
and all the different,
that just that the different incredible
structures that exist in Egypt that most
people don't even discuss.
Oh,
they don't know about and they don't
want to discuss it,
but chances,
I mean,
that's,
you know,
the way to really watch it because
people have told me this too.
I mean,
I'm not,
I'm not much into even dope by casually
smoke at in a while.
And I'm not much,
Bob Cares.
My vice such as it is,
I don't even consider it vicious.
But um,
watching that,
a couple of talks to watch magical it
with a couple of Tux cause it slows
things down.
The editing on that as,
as breathtaking and there's a hypnotic
quality to it.
It's really,
I mean it's an extraordinary achievement
in shock.
Did it on second shock.
I mean chance did it on a zero budget,
you know,
and doing all of the photography,
I mean everything single handed on
nothing.
It's really the heroic production and,
and you know,
and we made nothing out of it.
Let's try to get it on Netflix.
I really want,
I'm going to try to make an attempt so
when you attend,
yeah,
I will.
I'm going to try to make an attempt.
I'm going to bring it to them and have a
conversation with them.
Yeah.
They stink.
Give,
give him a copy.
They might not even know.
You know,
I mean I,
I guarantee they don't,
they don't have a lead out now.
I really think it's one of the great
works.
I think it's to May and it's so in
depth.
It's so in depth into the only way you
could do it was to self produce it.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
You couldn't get anyone to do that and
nobody would go,
you're going to do eight dvds on enough.
What are you out of your mind?
Nobody's going to watch all that.
I watch it like three or four times.
Lots of people do.
I mean people,
you have a magical Egypt too,
right?
Well we're working on it.
We don't have the funding and then
actually this is chances baby now cause
I'm,
anytime he wants me I'm there for him.
But I'm not in any position to to really
help with it because I'm so swamped with
my own stuff.
But yeah,
he covered in magical Egypt.
I don't know.
We've got the first one semi done,
but I don't know what he's got in mind.
And this is what Australia,
so I don't get to see him.
The doll and it's even skype is,
is not good for in depth,
evening long conversation.
No,
I don't know.
But I'll bet if you showed it to Netflix
and they expressed an interest,
he'd be interested,
well I'm going to do that.
I'm going to do that.
I'm going to bring them a copy.
We're going to see what we could do.
I think it's,
it's one of those things that I really
believe that people should say.
Oh that and I think that if you could
get it on Netflix and I could tweet it
and let the world know and try to get
people to spread the word.
I think once people see it,
they just start like that making of a
murderer thing.
You know,
that that caught all that traction
entirely because it was on Netflix and
word of mouth mostly.
I really think that,
that,
that magical Egypt is one of those
things.
Yeah.
Well what I would like to do actually,
and I hope my pal clay and some other
people are going to help me with this.
I'd like to get some of my other,
when I'm wearing my other hat and my,
my uh,
my writers,
my Bohemian Barei instead of my Egypt,
a logical pith helmet.
Cause I've got a,
I mean a whole lifetimes worth of work,
much of which has been produced but none
of it really,
um,
commercially successful.
And it just sitting there waiting to get
done.
And netflix would be the perfect venue
for it if I had something to show him.
Um,
you know,
because they do production,
I mean they,
they're producers now too.
It's an interesting time.
I mean that's one of the best things
about the internet is that something
like that can kind of spring up and
become a bigger net worth than any of
the networks on television.
You know,
that's,
that's the upside.
Well the networks are about to die and
good riddance.
Well it's a silly idea what,
it was good back when there was no other
ideas.
You had to sit through those commercials
and wait for the next segment and then
you watch 10 minutes and the is popped
on again.
You rolled your eyes and waited for the
commercials again and that all that
stuff's nonsense.
Now you watch a commercial,
now you're like,
what is this silly thing?
Well the Internet's full of commercials.
So it is,
it is,
but at least,
uh,
at least they're usually at the
beginning of a video and then in the
middle,
sometimes things near there.
Anyway.
Anyway,
magical.
Egypt is awesome.
You're awesome.
Appreciate you coming on.
And Joe,
glad we got a chance to meet in person.
It's a big difference even though skype
is the next best thing.
Yeah.
Two,
three dimensional meeting.
It isn't three dimensional meetings.
Not as fun to be here.
And thanks for inviting me.
Thank you.
And thank you for all of your work cause
I think you've done a great service to
the world to sort of shine light on this
amazing civilization.
Much appreciate it.
All Right Ladies and gentlemen is it's,
thank you very much John Anthony West.
Go seek out as work and definitely go by
magical Egypt.
Don't pirate it.
You fucks.
Go buy it.
That's awesome.
Exactly.
And,
and,
and if you have the money and the way I
have the wherewithal and the will get on
an Egypt trip,
get on an age of trump,
this man,
because I'm good enough to get up and
down the pyramid.
But who knows what,
how long exact,
so,
uh,
I'll ride strike while the irons hot.